So you think that they you think Nick Shirley is like what do
you think he's like a that's not the argument you think >> could
be? We don't know. I have just as much evidence of >> Oh,
he doesn't like that they're Listen, I will jokingly say that
Nick Shirley is Let me see those kids. Let me record those. Can
I record those kids? Can I get those kids on camera real quick?
Hey man, can I see those kids? I just want to see the kids, man.
>> Nick as I do of Nick presenting evidence that these
places are doing fraud. Now, later down the line, some of these
places might actually be proven to be fraudulent, but that doesn't
mean that Nick actually presented any evidence to suggest that
they are.
And without further ado, let's get into the Hassan [__]
coverage. Hassan [__] versus Asmin Gold. Uh, listen,
I heard about this and we're going to check it out. Asmin Gold
and Hassan started sniping back and forth. It started with Asold
responding to like a Hassan chatter on stream and then eventually
Hassan goes and starts quote unquote tapping on the glass. Okay.
Hassan be tapping on the glass a lot. There's already a video.
What? What do you mean there's already a video?
Is Assan about to get um possibly. But nobody in his audience
will ever know it. That's why I'm saying this is the only unbiased
broadcast to get analysis on the situation. Okay. I've read the
facts. I can say who is right. I can say who is wrong. I'm the
only one. All right. Nobody else has actually read the facts.
Also, there will never be a satisfying resolution to the Somali
immigrant scandal immigrant scandal in Minnesota. The evidence
required to prosecute old cases of fraud likely doesn't exist
anymore and can't be reproduced. So,
while attendance records are required to be kept for a long period
of time,
when these attendance records don't exist, you can't charge somebody
with fraud. You have to be able to prove fraud beyond a reasonable
doubt. What they'll be able to charge these people with is like
reckless or or bad bookkeeping. And I don't think the penalties
for bad bookkeeping will ever rise to the level of the fraud
they engaged in. And so it's likely there will never be justice
in this case. And we will never be able to find out or figure
out like what exactly the level of fraud was.
>> At the end of the day, they understand that they're
never going to get punished for hiring undocumented workers.
That's the whole point of the system.
>> The whole point of the system is to hire undocumented
workers and then [__] on them over and over again.
So, no one actually decides no one actually decides to document
these people. Okay? Because if they do, then their bottom lines
are going to be in threat. They're going to be under scrutiny.
The system is designed this way. That's why I get very frustrated
with people who do this fake populist.
Okay? people who do this fake populist while simultaneously leaning
into the propaganda that billionaires and millionaires and and
capitalists are actually leaning into as aggressively as possible.
Anytime you think the real problem is just another person, your
neighbor and in the case of the Somali migrants that we're talking
about, they're all American citizens. 60% of them are natural-born
US citizens. 90% overall are uh naturalized and natural-born
US citizens. So, they have American citizenship.
I'm so immune. I'm completely immune to this criticism because
I have said, "Okay, Rick Scott. [__] Rick Scott."
All right. [__] Rick Scott in every possible
So, when he says this, I understand he's going after Asmin Gold.
I don't fall into that camp. Okay.
Rick Scott should get what any one of these Somalies gets. Okay.
In terms of prison time, in terms of anything. Rick Scott when
you do you think he's brave enough to bring Rick Scott up again?
Who the [__] is Rick Scott? Former governor of Florida,
I believe. Was he governor or senator of Florida? He was a he
was a politician from Florida who engaged in the largest Medicare
fraud in American history. Senator. Okay. Senator. Yes. He had
a company that engaged in the largest Medicare fraud in US history.
He reached out to me privately said he wasn't talking about you.
Well, I'm saying but I still have criticisms for Hassan and the
Somali community. And I don't think if you have a focus on the
Somali community here or if you're willing to talk about the
Somali community, that means your opinion should be discarded.
I disagree with this. I think there's clearly a problem with
the Somali community that Hassan is sweeping for. He's got the
broom out and he's sweeping for the Somali. Okay. It's crazy.
Actually, put the beat on those guys and say, "Nope, these guys
are all bad. You're doing the bidding of the likes of Elon Musk.
And that's precisely the reason why they love this and they pump
it all day, every day, any moment.
>> Because we're on Twitch right now, we usually do the
stream on multiple platforms, but because we're on Twitch right
now, I cannot actually say my opinion. Suffice to say, Hassan
didn't ever advocate for Rick Scott. Okay? And I have criticisms
of that opinion.
I have criticisms of that opinion. Okay.
Rick Scott is a terrible person. Rick Scott is evil. Rick Scott
should be treated as a traitor to the United States of America.
Defrauding the government of money is traitorous. He should be
denaturalized in whatever way you want to denaturalize these
Somali. Yeah. Get Rick Scott out of the country too. Okay. This
guy has done crimes against the American people. Get him the
out of the country. Why is he involved in your politics? Get
them the out thinking that other people in this country, undocumented
migrants in this country or documented migrants of a different
background than yours is actually causing you harm. any moment
that you spend on that silly ass notion and not uh realize that
it is actually the the the real power players here, people like
Elon Musk, billionaires, millionaires, and and uh big corporations
that are actually dominating your lives is a moment that you're
defending them. Then it is worth 300k likes. Reagan Somali Tik
Tocker threatens Elon Mus's life. I wouldn't worry too much about
him. He about to die. Protect Elon Musk at all costs. Then it
is war. This is like a random Tik Tocker. Man, you're the wealthiest
person on the Dude, that's actually hilarious. Hold on, hold
on, hold on. That is hilarious. Small Tik Tocker threatens Elon
Musk's life. I wouldn't worry too much about him. He's about
to die.
Then it is war. I will go to war. Dude, Elon Musk could probably
buy a militia that could take over Somalia. Okay. He could probably
take over the real country, let alone just, you know, going engaging
in whatever with random US citizens.
Like like it's not uh you're saying it's war. That's really weird.
Okay. That's just really odd. >> Then it is war. This is
like a random Tik Tocker, man. You're the >> dude. That's
like It's like going to [__] You remember when you
were a kid and there was those pictures of those starving kids
in Africa? You remember the picture of the vulture that's like
looking at the African kid that's starving? It's like Elon Musk
goes there and one of them's like, "You're ugly." And he's like,
"Then it is war." With like a starving African child. Then it
we will be war. You say I'm ugly. Then it is war.
Like dude, can you chill? Are you Do you have any sense of like
the scale of who you are versus who these people are? Is there
anything going on in that dumb head of your yours? Your empty
[__] head. What is your problem? Wealthiest person
on the planet. What do you mean this is war? Is there a reason
we don't think that people like Asmold is being paid by capital
to push this? No. There are always going to be useful idiots
in general. Um or or not even useful idiots necessarily, but
useful idiots that know. >> The crazy thing Hassan doesn't
understand that within every Asmin Gold viewer, I don't know
how he doesn't see it. Beats the heart of a Hassan fan. All he
has to do as Hassan is start reaching out to those people instead
of being like disgusted by them. He just needs to tell them like
listen they are you over but we just mean somebody else when
we say they they are you over he literally has the same script
as gold. He's got a very similar script. Okay. You just need
to convince them that your they makes more sense than they're
they.
I don't know why he he goes so hard at them because it makes
him a lot of money and it's just like the thing you should do
I guess as Hassan. But like you you can convince those people.
They are very much people who are able to come over to your camp.
But I wait Hassan's they isn't isn't Jews. It's just rich people
in the United States. Okay. Stop saying O. Stop saying stop saying
O in the chat right now. I demand >> peaceful idiots that
uh that that know that there is a lot of clout that you can gain,
a lot of prominence that you can farm off of this when you have
the wealthiest person on the planet who owns his own social media
platform promoting you. When you say stuff like this, when you
play along with their goals, when you shift people's attention
away from the the corporate igopoly, constant corporate consolidation,
endless amounts of lobbying, endless amounts of subsidies that
they acrew as a consequence of endless amounts of lobbying, and
you just redirect that attention back to random people, your
neighbors, your comm
people really fall for this contrarian. Wait, Hassan's contrarian
or my contrarian [__] Because the answer is yes to
both. But I actually don't exactly know what you mean. So, Buck
Society, thank you for the new sub. 12 months. Let's go. Han
is bad. Hassan is bad. Also, I got paid to do the
I don't know what this guy means by do people really fall for
this constraint the the Hassan or me. I don't know which the
answer is yes to >> communities and decide whole cloth
that every single person okay uh every single uh person that
is coming from like a Somali background is actually engaging
in some level fraud. It makes the real fraudsters get away with
it in broad daylight. the biggest. See, this is the thing is
he's he's probably
actively engaging in the exact problem Asmin Gold is pointing
out, which is weird for me because I understand there's like
this actual the actual arguments here are something like, well,
yeah, there is a focus on the Somali community and yeah, it does
make sense to focus on the Somali community because it seems
like the fraud is disproportionately relevant there, but you
shouldn't do it because sometimes you'll hit like a false positive
and you will judge a Somalian business owner
like unfairly.
That's like Hassan's position. And for me, it feels like that
sort of thinking has led to the place where it was like 2019,
it was pointed out even before 2019. In 2019, the fraud had like
reached ahead. The investigators were like, "Yeah, this fraud
happens more than we could possibly keep up with. The bar for
evidence is so high and the the recordkeeping is so bad. We can't
prove fraud beyond a reasonable doubt because of the recordeping.
It's not that we don't think fraud is happening. We know fraud
is happening. We've seen it. Widespread fraud. But literally,
the record keeping is so bad that all we could really charge
these people with is bad recordkeeping.
And honestly, they should have done that. Every single they should
have gone around and said every single person who is doing this
kind of business, who's starting this kind of business, who is
failing to keep their records correctly, those people should
be out of the business. They shouldn't be able to run that business
anymore. You're up all your record keeping. Well, that's actually
important. That's what this whole system relies on, right? The
Minnesota system was a system of like operating on faith until
there was some allegation against you. Okay?
That's how the Minnesota system worked was they basically when
you had an allegation against you, they would investigate it.
They would ask for your attendance records and repeatedly what
would what they would find is the attendance records were illeible,
were poorly connect collected, didn't have didn't make any sense.
Okay, they ran out of money to prosecute as well several times
just from the sheer volume. I actually don't know that this is
the the case. I don't remember reading that, but it could have
been in there. Sounds like somewhat reasonable. Essentially,
what they were arguing was the cost of the investigations is
so high that like you can get one of these businesses on fraud
and eight more will pop up. I said eight. That's not actually
the allegation. It's just several more will pop up. Okay. So,
the fraud was bad. It was it was pervasive.
It was highly prevalent.
And they were unable they were unable sorry not enable they were
incapable of dealing with it unable to deal with it. And instead
of like really approaching this problem in a proactive way it
seemed like they just went well we think you guys are racist.
Well we we can't really do it. And it just got caught in like
a government purgatory for for years.
And so I don't think Hassan's
like engagement with this is helpful. I think it's the exact
kind of engagement you'd expect from Democrats that led to a
total lack of movement on this problem for quite a while.
At the same time, I totally agree with Hassan in that I don't
want innocent like hardworking American immigrants prosecuted
or persecuted for their ethnicity, their skin color. I I don't
want that. I sincerely don't want that. And so, how do you solve
this problem? I don't know. It's actually really tricky. I don't
think you can solve this problem specifically. I think this problem
is going to exist forever. This problem literally the records
are already bad. The records will never exist such that fraud
can be like actually pursued against these people. There will
never be like fraud cases proven. The best you will ever be able
to do is say, "Well, they didn't have their attendance records
and we're going to penalize them under like what the penalty
is for failing to keep proper records." The issue is that if
he bites the bullet on that framing re Somali's, it's like tacitly
conceding to all the people that want you to conclude that it's
because of some inherent trait and he get yelled at by his chat.
This is true. Yes, people like literally can't get people literally
can't be honest about it because if he's honest about it for
2 seconds, that's the only thing that'll get clipped. If he goes,
"Yeah, I understand that there's a problem with fraud in the
Somali community." If he ever says that, that's all that will
be clipped and they'll go, "Hassan actually believes there's
fraud, but he won't admit it." Hassan believes there's fraud.
Hassan Hassan Hassan Hassan said it's happening, but he doesn't
want to do anything about it, right? There's literally no possible
good faith engagement that can happen. And so I'm sitting here
and I'm like, "Okay, I can cover this. I'm a small creator. I
can cover this. I'm not, you know, I'm not audience captured
in a political sense. Might be audience captured in some other
ways. Not in a political sense. I can just be honest about this,
okay? The whole time I can explain to you where Hassan's right,
where he's wrong, where Asmin Gold's right, where Asmin Gold's
wrong. I can do both. This fraudster of all time is Elon Musk.
Any moment that you spend not on people like Elon Musk
is a moment where people like Elon Musk get away with it. So
you can keep saying, "Oh, I hate big corporations." and engage
in this fake populism, this empty populism, or as I like to call
it, you should have like some idea of how to spread blame around.
And even I'm guilty of this cuz it's incredibly difficult to
keep like the properly weighted model in your mind of who's to
blame for like society's ills at any given time. It's incredibly
difficult. Almost nobody's capable. Okay. Essentially, nobody's
capable. But like I do think Elon Musk's the like the what would
you say the source of a lot of woes in society probably disproportionately
so cuz he's so rich. The Somalian fraud here is a problem and
it is attributable significantly to one community and that is
a problem and there are a lot of problems that go along with
that. That community is not growing. That community is not figuring
out how to exist. Right? Like here's the thing. Let's say they
were committing fraud and you can't prove it and you even get
people to buy into like we should let this go. How are those
people going to live now?
Those people were living by doing this whole scam thing. Let's
say they were actually scamming the whole time. How are they
going to live now? What are they going to be doing in Minnesota
now? They have not figured out how to integrate and make themselves
like significantly helpful in society or at least that that seems
to be the case. I I'll say in this hypothetical we'll say that's
the case.
What are they doing now? How do you even get them caught up?
Why do you want them to live? Because I'm not a murderer. They
can live on the streets. Okay. What do you think, MOONRAY MURRAY?
AS A RACIST, what do you think a massive population of homeless,
poor, destitute blacks is going to do in Minnesota?
Listen to what you just said.
Yeah, you're a racist. You should you should abhore that idea.
You should be terrified of that idea. You just want a roving
pack of homeless blacks on the street in Minnesota in Minneapolis.
Again, I'm not racist. I don't believe that. Okay. But I'm telling
you, you're saying they could live on the streets. What do you
think happens when they do that? Prove what they are good at.
Yeah, they haven't done that. I don't I don't know if they've
done that. What percentage of the Somali community is involved
in the scheme? A pretty high amount. Like like uh not 50%. Not
like all of them, but a significant percentage. I'd say involved
in any way. It might go really high, but it's it's impossible
for me to say. I don't know. But it seemed like a lot of these
daycarees operated by getting moms to bring their kids in, and
then they would be the people who worked there, and they would
all sort of collect a portion of this money that would come from
the government. That seems to be how it worked. Now, it's like
single digits. It's not single digits if it works the way the
investigators says it say it do. Say it does. Yeah. Not single
digits. It's almost certainly double digits.
If you want to say people benefiting massively from the fraud,
that would be very low. That would be very low. Um, but in terms
of the people who are involved in some way, a lot like a lot.
A lot a lot a lot. I don't think people would be mad if the Somali
community was essentially an underclass that were making decent
money actually providing these services like homeare and childare
services.
I suspect if you really broadly audited these companies
and got them to include all of their their people from outside
that's probably how you would find the people who operating in
good faith. How many people have someone from outside of the
Somali community like a kid who goes to their daycare and that
kid and the parents of that kid give really good reviews to that
daycare?
That would probably be the bar for me of like looking for the
people who are operating in good faith because almost certainly
some of them do operate in good faith. That'd be like 5,000 people.
I do believe there's hundreds of these Somali businesses in the
state of Minnesota and there's probably at least two or three
people involved at each of these 100 businesses. So, you do get
up to 5,000 people pretty quickly. The 9 bill billion figure
isn't crap with the moms though, right? Isn't Isn't this the
9 billion figure is crap? I think is what you meant to say. Sorry,
I'm reading private huff here saying isn't crap. I think the
9 billion figure is
but it's possible there's been a lot of fraud over the years.
Is it nine billion? I don't think so. I think that's pretty crazy.
But it does seem like there's a lot of fraud across medical service
companies or like care companies in this Somali community.
Now, with the assisted living care facilities, you could look
at that. I don't know that there's been fraud proven the assisted
living care facilities. Like assisted living
we'd have to go and look at that. For transportation businesses,
David said there were a thousand registered and over 800 were
Somali owned. So, you just have to Yeah, you'd have to go and
look at all of this stuff, right?
And basically, I think what you have to do is you have to require
digital recordkeeping, which is what a bunch of these people
have done now that the law just got passed on January 1st, like
yesterday or the day before it got passed. It was like in the
middle of this week, the law got passed that's going to require
digital recordkeeping for the CCAP program.
And that will be key to like deterring this stuff going forward.
But I don't even know what that's going to look like, like shockingly.
We'll see. I hope it's not some easily exploitable system again
because realistically there's only so many times people can really
let this
in my opinion. Anyway, we should go back to the video here. Slobulism,
right? But every moment that you do that while simultaneously
shifting the anxieties and the the the
anger and resentment people feel towards,
you know, entire
whole swath. Oh, hold on. I assume PPP loans PPP loan payouts
are being added into the estimates, right? I have no idea. Turniguit
I actually I literally don't know. As far as I know, the fraud
that happened with feed our kids, I don't think that was PPP
stuff. I think that was different. That was like actually um
some food
some like meals program that they were defrauding with that.
>> So the population >> or sorry feed our futures
>> that have been living here for decades at this point,
right?
is a moment where Elon Musk gets to keep stealing. It's the LBJ
quote that you can slam in here every single time. Not LeBron
James, of course. I'm talking about LBJ the president. Okay?
If you can convince the lowest white man that he is better than
the best colored man, he won't notice you're picking his pocket.
Hell, give him somebody to look down on and he'll empty his pockets
for you. That's what's going on.
The rough thing for me here is Hassan has the script for literally
everything that happens that's racist. And so I don't think Hassan
does a lot of analysis on the facts of the matter in most of
these cases,
right? He's not doing a deep dive on the facts of the matter.
He is mostly going like, "Well,
these people are racist. Don't pay too much attention. These
people are
I I don't like that. And obviously I'll have as much criticism
once we start hearing Asminold speak. I'll have as much criticism
for him. I promise. Well, I shouldn't promise. I will if he's
making the same kinds of claims because I think Asminold is doing
the same thing.
Asminold's just applying his script to this with zero analysis
of the facts. It just happens to be that I think Asminold's script
fits slightly better than Hassan's here. All of this other stuff
is just culture war. Yeah, the enemy is the 1%. It's the billionaires
versus the rest of us. MAGA keeps distracting us with culture
wars as they drink all of our milkshake. And that's precisely
what's happening here. Okay. America's 15 richest billionaires
got $1 trillion richer as the affordability crisis became a top
concern in 2025. And you're out here. You're out here complaining.
You're out here complaining. You think like the the Somali are
the top 1%. This is how it's been. And the more you focus on
undocumented migrants are stealing our jobs and also stealing
our welfare, the more you lean into this dumb [__]
Okay, the more you hyperfocus on this element of fraud and not
fraud being tackled in its entirety, which would require us to
take a closer look at these guys as well because they are the
biggest fraudsters,
right? Any moment that you're hyperfocusing on that, you're doing
their bidding.
again I feel like that's not true and you can do both at the
same time and understand that probably going after Elon Musk
or Elon Musk related fraud or his government contracts or his
that's like a way more complicated issue than this one. So I
I disagree that you can't focus on both. Um I would say probably
you should never totally focus on this and like only have this
in mind. But right now it's like a new cycle. It's not wrong
to focus on it during the news cycle or to get information on
it during the news cycle.
I don't think I don't like the idea of like close your eyes.
Close your eyes and don't pay attention.
It's all racist trying to block you, trying to trying to cut
you off from everyone, trying to make you like focus on, you
know, the black people who are stealing from you when you should
focus on the you should focus on one kind of African, but it's
a South African. I cannot believe it. I cannot believe how
this commentary actually is. And that's it's so successful that
people literally do it even in this chat where they go, "Oh,
you're talking about billionaires and millionaires. Aren't you
a millionaire?" There it is politics and then they subverted
identity politics
and distorted it into allowing in a bunch of unskilled laborers
and now we're paying for it.
>> Identity politics
is not about like defending unskilled laborers, brother. What?
Oh my god.
Economics is not a zero- sum game.
Uh, that's true.
That's true. Um, it's zero- sum for
Essentially, you should think of economics as a as like a what
is it? Like a flow system, like a system with flow. And right
now there's really high there's a really high pressure differential
between America and everywhere else where like that pressure
represents like I I guess like cost to produce like economic
value and and basically all people have been working on for the
past 30 years is ways to relieve that pressure and allow it to
escape to other countries. And so America it is a zero- sum game.
You are losing money um not just to Americans to foreign labor.
You are constantly losing money. your labor is constantly being
devalued as the globe gets better at working within the global
economic marketplace. Okay? So, it is a zero- sum game for Americans.
For everybody else, no, it's not. It's literally not. But, uh,
for Americans, for American citizens, the average American citizen,
it is. Every You're in a dire situation.
And nobody wants to admit that for some reason. It's very shocking.
>> Unskilled laborers, too. That's the Oh my god. Unskilled
labor is [__] Okay.
These people play an incredibly important role in the productive
forces. This necessary labor, okay? Like it's it's additionally
funny for a Twitch streamer to say this. You know, this is the
ultimate says you moment.
What kind of skill do you have? At least I recognize that I'm
not actually a part of the productive forces engaging in socially
necessary labor [laughter] here. I'm stret
to to have the audacity to say this kind of stuff. That's how
that's how it happened. And if I I don't know why people don't
understand. I don't I I think that people don't want to admit
that they got got, but people have been got. They totally got
got.
They slowly boiled us. Yeah. I mean, that's what I think has
happened. Like, I think you can be angry about this. I do think
overall
you should be more upset about the fact that your labor is being
devalued, that like you can't prevent it from escaping and that
any economic policy that could prevent it from escaping is going
to be economically inefficient. Therefore, totally shunned by
both sides of the political aisle, right?
Realistically, if you're an American, you should argue in your
interest. You should vote in your interests. Hey, is somebody
going to pass laws that prevent my labor from being devalued?
WAIT, NO. THAT'S THAT'S ACTUALLY economics is not a zero- sum
game. You shouldn't you shouldn't advocate for anything like
that. Well, hold on. Well, it's not a zero- sum game, but I want
like the capital side, the the richer person side to lose out
a little bit. I don't want my side to keep losing. Why does my
side get eternally? My side, they're like, "Yeah, um actually
all these billionaires, all these like productive um extremely
wealthy people in the country, their their share of the pie keeps
going up or keeps like staying stagnant." And your share of the
pie is like a worker in America keeps getting lower and lower.
You keep getting more and more. Now, if people want access to
the American market, if people want access to like American capital,
I do believe there should be costs to that.
But hey, I don't know.
Oh, I forgot they have the signs up because they can't figure
out how to change the uh the letters. >> This is property
of the the restaurant, right? Go over there. Uhhuh. >> Is
this property of the daycare or the restaurant? Let me Is this
Is this productive? Angela Rose, the owner's son says his lawyer
said he is not allowed to talk and responded no statement when
I asked him to talk or when I asked to talk to him. The parking
sign says it's the restaurant parking only, which I got take
out at, but the childcare sides is telling me to get off. Five
stars for the food, one star for customer treatment. A car full
of men pulled in and shouted, "Where's the kids?" Recently, my
real concern is where are the senior citizens? Surely they have
accidentally escaped as all those centers are empty and lack
signage as
Okay, I the the citizen journalist thing is just gay. Uh you
buying a microphone does not make you a journalist. Do any amount
of due diligence. Holy [__] >> This is cringe.
>> I wish this was happening in Texas. At least we get
to watch some really awesome body cam footage. Okay. Or some
really awesome like CCTV footage of people coming up be like,
"Where's the kids?" You just hear like the pump. Okay. I wish
it was happening in Texas.
>> Yeah. But >> yesterday I ate I got some takeout
from Albi Kitchen and so I'm allowed to be
>> This is the kitchen's parking lot.
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. >> Who's this chick? Nikki
Early. >> Wait, what?
Nikki. Okay, good one. Good one. Reban Ruben,
>> don't come. Go over there if you want,
>> But I order >> What did she just say? She got
take out from the restaurant, so she's allowed to be there. some
food from LB Kitchen. And this is the kitchen. >> I just
noticed. Do you know what's not in this video at all? There's
no parents walking to and from uh the daycare at all. This is
a horrible from Asthma Gold. What time is it? The whole point
of daycare is hold on. The whole point of daycare is you drop
your kids off and then you go to work, right? That's the whole
point of daycare. That's what daycare is. Like if she's there,
depending on what time she's there, there literally wouldn't
be kids there. There wouldn't be parents coming in and out. There
wouldn't be Does he think like parents just randomly go to drop
kids off at at daycare or >> Oh, I know this is just a
one minute video, but it's important to keep that in mind. >> Parking
lot. >> No, this is my property. Please go >> the
owner. >> Please go over there. >> Are you the owner?
Are you the owner of the property? >> Go over there. >> Oh,
okay. Are you also the owner of Quality Learning? >> I
don't want to talk. Go. >> It seems like you want to talk.
Seems like he wants to talk. He must have It must be lonely just
standing there
making like yelling at people all day. >> I think he he
does want to talk. I wonder like what's the border
>> even if you think all of these people are fraudulent?
Every smallie business in the state of Minnesota is fraudulent.
Who supports this? Who supports like going as like a 100 different
independent journalists quote unquote with a microphone and a
selfie stick and just being like, "WHERE ARE THE KIDS? WHERE
ARE THE KIDS? HEY, WHAT'S THIS? WHAT'S THIS? WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE?" so worthless. These people are less valuable to society.
At least there's the potential for this daycare to take care
of kids. This person has the potential to do nothing. This person
has no potential. This person is worthless.
This person is a total economic drain. >> Like, can I stand
here? >> This response applies to Asmin's ideology. You
don't need to engage with other people if you don't want uh to
according to him. Yeah, of course. But when the when the person
is is of Somali background, obviously then harassing them and
loitering around their property alongside like hundreds of other
goblins is totally appropriate, totally valid.
>> Do anything.
>> Is this okay? Can I be right here? >> They covered
the sign. Did they really? Let me see. [laughter] >> What
a bunch of man. Oh. Oh, did she this when they were fixing it?
I think they they updated the sign or something. This must be
when they're fixing it, right? Oh my god. >> Is this okay?
Can I be right here?
>> Yeah. Why am I not surprised?
>> Can I stand here?
>> This is just for views. It is just for views. But I
do think that isn't it weird that >> Where's the senior
citizens? >> Oh yeah, we just watched him do this clicks
on video. Yeah. Yeah, dude. This video makes a pretty good point.
Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty true. Pause the
Okay. But unfortunately for Hassan, Asminagold just totally like
ripped this whole point. Unfortunately, he just totally won here.
I like
we all admit that he totally won, right? Uh yeah. Yeah, dude.
This makes a pretty good point. Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty true.
Pause his video. What he said is really true, actually. Unpause
the video. Nods along more. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. That's how it
is. He's right. He is right.
Yeah. He just responds, "Yeah, god damn >> What he just
said is really true, actually. Unpause the nods along more. Yeah.
Yeah.
People who watch and donate money to this nonsense need to be
called. Yeah. Yeah. He he he does have the he does often have
a >> uh is Hassan advocating for all Asminold fans live
ON TWITCH? DAN SALMAN. DAN SMAN.
HASSAN JUST SAID YOU SHOULD KILL ASMOLD FANS. LET'S GET HIM OFF
THE
>> Tendency to just be like, "Oh, I'm laughing along with
everybody actually about this thing."
It's so funny. Yeah.
Yeah. Based. >> And also, I don't feel bad for these guys.
I really don't. You shouldn't have been scamming. And now you
have all Americans everywhere coming in here trying to figure
out what's actually going. dog. If they are scamming,
let the actual investigators
conduct a investigation.
This is not how this goes, man. This is not how anything goes.
This is how you know that Hassan didn't read the report. Okay?
He would never read the report.
Let the investigators investigate. Investigate what? Investigate
how? This is just pure
What are we doing on here? The sign was fixed a few days ago.
It actually says learning center. By the way, I will say the
scam is not having zero kids. Okay? The scam is absolutely not
having zero kids. The scam is running a business, getting a certain
like cap on how many kids you can have, bringing your own kids,
maybe getting kids from some other place if you're being investigated,
and then running the daycare for like those two, three, four
kids. Your own kids. Okay? That's what the scam is. You got like
a bunch of workers. You got very few kids and you're running
this business and then when the investigators aren't there, you're
reporting just a couple more kids or maybe a lot more kids than
you were actually taking care of. That's the scam. It's not having
zero kids like Nick Shirley and that boomer said. Oh, there's
no kids. I've never seen kids. Well, there are kids,
but it's that's not what that's not what's happening. Okay. And
not only that, these people have been investigated already. Like,
a lot of these people have been investigated. Quality Learning
Center has been investigated under a different name. >> Now,
Trump pardoned the guy guilty of billions of medicines
for this at all. That's crazy. >> Wow. Wow. That's sad.
Really? Is you got people like this, you just ask a simple question,
you can't even answer the
Okay, he typed something. What do you type? I hear a lot about
this girl in the image community. You guys hear a word about
the fraud from Trump has ever conducted himself. No, you you
now you're changing what you're saying. When did I ever say that
I was uh uh I was okay or that the guy pardoning him from is
fine. Like what do you think that I think about that? >> Disinguous
from as gold. Answer the core criticism which is you give way
more thought and and pay way more mind to the this immigrant
community doing fraud than like the billions in fraud Trump and
his cronies are perpetrating actively in the on the American
people. You care way more about this. That's the meat of the
criticism. As Gold, don't run from it. Okay. Yeah, I understand.
You can like carve out a little piece of that criticism that
you could go, "Well, I didn't say it was okay. I never said it
was fine." Yeah, I understand you could do that. Okay.
>> It's a simple question.
>> Like, you're talking about some other [__]
question. Why can't you just answer the question? >> Oh,
no. You're getting You're getting people. You're getting Wait,
wait, wait,
>> When did I ever say that? >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, >> You're going to put words in my mouth
and get mad at them. I mean like
you >> Oh, by the way, guys, if you have uh Twitch primes,
I want you, if you're in the kick chat, you got Twitch primers.
There's the Twitch link. Go follow on Twitch, go open the Twitch
link and and give me your primers. Okay, primers. Any primers
out here? >> Why do other people do this to you? Damn.
This is professionally what you do to me. >> You want to
demonize an immigrant community when you lose sight of the real
issues in this country?
>> Uh yeah, because they're scamming us. That's what's
happening. I mean, are they not scamming? How much time and emphasis
has Asmin go placed on criticizing big daddy Trump?
>> Division five player. Thank you for the primer. Thank
you. Thank you. >> If somebody >> pardoning all these
uh uh fraudsters. >> No, it's not changing [__]
around. It's paying attention to real. >> Wait. Audience
capture is definitely real. It's not. Why did you say it's a
tool used by That's
audience capture is definitely real. 100%.
>> 100%. What are you talking about? Matt Lt, thank the
>> primer. Appreciate it, man. Oh, wait. Division five
player was a tier one sub and then Matt Lt was the primer. Thank
you so much, guys. Thank you. Thank you.
>> So, let me get this straight.
You don't think that it's a real problem that you have an entire
community in an area that's defrauding the government for billions
of dollars? You don't think that's a problem? >> Type in
chat. He claims you're a mod. No, I can't. I got banned in his
chat. Look. Oh, wait. They unbanned me. I'm a VIP now. man for
>> they unbanned me. I guess [laughter] they I was banned
until like reason of their country.
>> Wait, I'm a VIP now. >> I used to be
>> You said you can't even measure a Jtock. It's just a
feeling. I can't You can't measure audience capture. Sure. But
like you can see somebody's opinions change over time and like
the audience paying them for those opinions essentially. It's
pretty easy to like you can get a feeling doesn't mean the feeling
is wrong. I have a feeling that there's a ton of fraud going
on here. I'd be willing to bet money. Like I I do believe sincerely
there's a ton of fraud going on in Minnesota that is largely
perpetrated by the Somali community. Just because I can't prove
that beyond a shadow of a doubt doesn't mean that's
>> Right.
Right. >> Time to mount. It's okay. >> He un he uh
unbanned me and then VIPed me. It seems >> I mean doesn't
that seem doesn't that seem odd? He's arguing with the optics
of your opinion, not the opinion. Yeah. I don't give a [__]
about like oh wow it's an immigrant community. I don't give a
[__] about that. Why would I care about that? They're
scamming. I like that it's now all Somali and other specific
people doing the fraud. Interesting. I mean, it's always been
the case. That's always been what it is. When uh when someone
actually when someone actually uh directly asks that question
though, he'll be like, "Oh, well, you know, uh I'm just talking
about the people who are doing it. I'm just talking about the
people who I'm suspecting of doing it." Okay? But that's what
it is. >> Maybe I'm not understanding, but it's cuz uh
it's a cause and effect issue. How do you know is the audience
eating the streamer or or the streamer swaying the audience?
Um, I think it's because you can see the streamer's opinions
change over time, right? And the audience is usually more like
I I guess aggressive in one direction. Like with Asmin Gold,
he's got like the the Gamergate audience, right? Like that's
that's the audience he's courted for a long time. Those people's
political opinions are pretty easily trackable over time. It's
like a very easy narrative. If you have a disagreement with it,
you could you could say it, but you can track his like community
and how they've progressed with like their political opinions
over time. I think as Miguel was more libertarian leaning, has
gone more towards like, well, Trump, it really isn't that bad.
I think the same thing happened to Adam and Sitch. They have
the very similar audience overlap. Um, not Sitch as much. I think
more Adam, right? Sitch has been pretty consistent and pretty
stalwart. I do think as gold's been moved a little bit. I think
Adam's been moved a lot. I think Sitch has been moved not very
much. But I I do think it happens. It happens to everybody, right?
Yeah, I just
I I understand you're saying that, oh well, you can't prove it.
I know I can't prove it. That's how I feel about it. That's all.
>> Do you think What do you think I I would want to do
with them? Fraud any capacity is bad. But to shine a light on
a community, that's a little drop in a bucket compared to actual
fraud going on on Tether is misled cuz people like you in the
media pick up attack communities. So, is it bad or so it's bad?
>> Everybody thinks it's bad when fraud is happening. Whether
it's a Somali American doing it or a white American doing it,
>> your hyperfocus and your priorities
and the way that you talk about it obviously the way you talk
about it obviously makes it seem as though you feel the entire
Somali American community is responsible for this fraud and it's
a mis it's a misdirection. It's a distraction away from the fraudsters
in the admin. >> Huge problem with the Somalian day.
I
agree with that, but at the same time, this needs to be fixed
because it's a huge drain on the like Minnesota childare system.
Like kids aren't getting free daycare or whatever in Minnesota
if this is the case, right? It does both need to be fixed. I
do think you could have a broad belief that the Trump administration
is the most fraudulent administration of all time and I think
I can stand on that and I don't think anybody could really try
to correct me on that. Right? You can believe that and also believe
that the Minnesota fraud stuff is a really big deal that there
are people like essentially rentseeking in this economy that
are providing nothing and that's got to go. >> Cares and
healthc care centers scamming money from the Minnesota government.
Do you think this is happening?
>> Well, I think private huff what people are saying is
this is like a big deal. This is too big a deal. People are making
too big a deal out of it. I don't think you could really tell
people they're making too big a deal out of it. And I think handling
this correctly and not telling people that they're overexaggerating
is actually key because there will never be prosecutions out
of this. Handling it correctly and and discerning like what the
correct level of blame and how you should talk about it. All
these things are important because they will determine how that
community is treated for the rest of time moving forward. And
if you just try to gaslight people and say nothing bad happened
here, that won't happen. The the racist will win. If you are
gaslighting people going, well, nothing bad happened here. You
can't prove anything bad happened here, so don't even talk about
it or think about it. I think the racist will basically win on
the back of that opinion. Now, the racist might win in the opinion
in the case where you talk about it. Maybe there's just no way.
But then America's you can't have an honest conversation and
everything's.
It's all over. Everything is done.
We're It's over. It's It's never been more over. Like uh hopefully
you can have an honest conversation with people about it, right?
Hopefully. The issue is The issue is it's just so much more effective
to rabble rouse. It's so much more effective to rabble rouse.
It is a little black pilling, but hey, here we're going to actually
try to analyze things and talk about it. And if you like that,
you can come around and you can talk about it with us. And if
you don't like that, well, there's a ton of communities. Trust
me, there's no shortage of leftwing or right-wing grifters.
There's no shortage. You can go find any of them. Find whatever
flavor you like. I'm just going to try my best to argue or or
to look up the facts and see what I think. And I'll even be honest
with you, I'm mostly by instinct reactionary, more populist leaning.
And I try to temper that with actually looking into things. Okay?
So you will see my natural reactions will be towards a more populist
or reactionary leaning. And then I will have to temper that by
going and finding facts and figuring out what I can support.
Okay? >> That's how I operate. If you don't like that,
that's fine. You don't have to be here. Can the jelly man, thank
you for the primer. Let's go and let's continue on with the stream.
I mean, if he's getting dunked on by chatters, of course, he's
not going to try conversation. >> Do you think it's happening?
Why won't you go after the real fraud? I have many times. I've
talked about it many times. >> You're make you're you're
you're jousting with windmills. You're arguing with something
that didn't happen.
>> Do you think it do you think it's happening or not >> in
Minnesota? >> Yeah, this is U. So, here's what's going
on. Okay. as soon as as soon as he is asked about his positions,
he has to back into a much more reasonable position. Yes, fraud
is fraud has taken place. Yes, the defendants uh in a an ongoing
fraud investigation
uh were were Somali Americans, right? This is true. This is real.
Except for the last 48 hours, for the last 76 hours in the media
cycle is not specifically the investigation that took place.
It's the notion that every single Somali is responsible. Every
single Somali business is uh victim to uh unlimited >> Um
haven't kept up. But have you checked out the coverage of any
of the shill dems? No, I have not. I've not looked at the Hutch
coverage. I've not looked at Soy Pill. Uh I I don't want to call
Soy Pill a Shill yet. Soy pill, he's like an enigma. I'm not
totally sure. Sometimes he has like bad opinions, but also he
seems far more likely to just go or far more capable of going
back and like actually looking through things. You know what
I'm saying?
I don't want to throw soy pill in that bucket just yet. Okay.
I I don't know what the coverage is like to be honest with you.
>> Move of other communities doing >> and he just
keeps shifting back and forth to try >> Did he say Did
he say 76 hours? I thought he said 72. Did he say 76? present
an argument that it's actually the grifter third worlders that
are parasitic that are just here to steal American funds. >> I
don't want to read this anymore. Hassan, you're 100%. Yeah, there's
fraud in every government. You're right. You're totally right
about that. Most definitely. That also includes the immigrant.
No, no. And this is also not Let me Let me go back and I I want
to make sure that we get this we get this nailed down. Do you
think that there is a very clear instance of a lot of these Somalianowned
daycarees and businesses that are defrauding Minnesota? This
is a yes or no question. Do you think that >> or not? There
is currently as it stands no evidence has been presented beyond
just going and knocking on their doors and screaming to see the
children expensive every year. How long is small fraud in comparison
to federal benefits you put out? Ah, >> there is a lot
of other there's a lot of other evidence of stuff. Oh my goodness.
There's there's so much other evidence of this. It's soed up
>> annually. A lot. And I bet if you go after that fraud,
you're going to find more of it. >> The real question in
this circumstance is, do you have any hard evidence as to all
of these businesses that are being visited
that are engaging in the type of fraud that that people are claiming
they're engaging in, as in there are no children there. There
have never been children there. They're simply lying about the
headcount and and doing it so they can get money. No child is
ever being taken care of. It's simply a way to make money at
all. That's why whenever I ask you like, "Is this happening?"
you're refraraming my question and then answering something I
didn't ask.
>> So, no. What about Oh, what about this? What about that?
What's the other thing? Listen, like I don't like any of it.
It's obvious that this isn't a problem. So, yeah, guys, of course.
And wait, that's crazy. Why are why are the people that are coming
after him in his chat infinitely nicer in their back and forth?
>> Why are all the people Why are all the unh people focusing
on
than his fans that come in here? When his fans come in here,
they're like, "Why are you a terrorist dog abuser piece? You
need to die." And like when he actually has people when he actually
has people that call into question his world view, it's always
like much nicer. It's like walking through it step by step. I
guess his fans are just much smarter than >> Democrat or
liberal. They'd be making >> I don't think Hassan could
have totally frame that as like, well, when my fans go to question
Asold, they're nice. When his fans come to question me, they're
evil. He could have easily said that >> excuses for it.
They don't give a about it. The only reason why they're bringing
it up is they're trying to create an artificial parody. It's
the same reason you remember like whenever they started trying,
they were talking about, oh, they're going to prosecute Hunter
Biden and oh well, we want to make sure everybody's treated the
same under the law, but then at the end of the day, on the last
day of Biden's presidency, Hunter Biden gets a presidential pardon.
That's like a blank check for the last 10 years. The reason why
is because they were doing that in order to create an artificial
parody between the way that Trump was being treated by the justice
system and also by the way Hunter Biden was being treated by
the justice system. So they only did that as a show. They don't
really care about the rules in care about >> Donald Trump
has infinitely more
instances of criminality that wasn't even prosecuted because
he became the
Hickor, thank you for the raid. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you.
>> And also, by the way, Hunter Biden was being treated
by the justice system. So, they only did that as a show. They
don't really care about the rules. Insane. They don't really
care about anything. >> Donald Trump has infinitely more
instances of criminality that wasn't even prosecuted because
he became the president as opposed to Hunter Biden. Okay. And
I'm not defending Hunter Biden or Biden's pardon at all. Who
gives? Yeah, Biden sucks and so does Hunter Biden. But the notion
the notion that Hunter Biden is like it reaches the same degree
of criminality as Donald Trump who was a a pivotal figure in
January 6 or even the people who did January 6
who trying to think even if you get all of Hunter Biden's like
fraud even if you take all of the allegations as true I don't
think it matches up to like some of the stuff alleged dude again
Tom Hman bag of cash a bag of cash okay
like how No, we don't stand Hunter Biden. Hunter Biden's a total
furler.
His dying husband's wife cheated on was was helped his wife cheat
on his dying brother with him. Hey, you you think you want to
somebody else while my brother's dying? Well, here's my dick.
Have you seen my dick? Have you considered my
kind of weird guy? Kind of a weird flor. Total fslur. Totally
immoral fur. That is a a like actually Oh, sounds like a Chad.
Yeah, Verain. This total Nepo baby who's never done anything
right in his life, who is rich and never had to work hard a day
in his life. That's the kind of guy you support. Literally had
never had to work hard a day in his life. Actually has faked
his way through everything in life. That's your That's your guy.
Okay. Yeah. >> Who are all pardoned?
>> I love Hunter Biden. He's totally immoral in every way.
He totally lied and tried to [__] over his dad multiple
times using his dad's name to trade trade like influence for
money. Yep. I love this guy. He's totally cool. Shut
That's ridiculous. >> I'm going to pull you're going to
get pulled up, too.
>> I see what this guy's saying.
Do you have any evidence that there's 100% fraud happening or
some YouTubers coming in there? Not saying that there isn't
>> Why? Why? Can you just let him read it? >> What
are you doing? >> To see the kids. Is that >> you?
You're saying this is like some thing about how Oh, well, you're
trying to see the kids.
Why are you saying see the kids?
Do you think that there was anything malicious or problematic
or bad that they had any sort of like weird intentions with trying
to see the kids? >> Yes. I know that anybody in Hunter's
field of work, which was I believe he's a lawyer, right? Yola.
I know that any lawyer who had the past he had with drugs, with
um failing to pay his taxes, all of the all of the behavior he's
exhibited, anybody who's from a lowass family who did that would
be for life. And he wasn't. That's what I know.
You can't roll up to a child care facility, whether there are
children there at that moment or not, and demand to see the children,
and then assume that this is like conclusive evidence that there's
no kids there. >> That's manipulation. No, listen to what
he's saying. It's okay. There's legit tons of the issues. And
yes, I think
you think that they you think Nick Shirley is like what? Do you
think he's like a >> That's not the argument. >> You
think it's a >> could be. We don't know. I have just as
much evidence of Oh, he doesn't like that they're Listen, I will
jokingly say that Nick Shirley is Let me see those kids. Let
me record those. Can I record those kids? Can I get those kids
on camera real quick? Hey, man. Can I see those kids? I just
want to see the kids, >> Nick, as I do of Nick presenting
evidence that these places are doing fraud. Now, later down the
line, some of these places might actually be proven to be fraudulent,
but that doesn't mean that Nick actually presented any evidence
to suggest that they are. You can't just show up to a child facility,
ask to go see kids. He could be he could be I don't know. >> That's
the whole point. >> I've never known the guy. >> That's
the whole point. He could file. You don't know. That's part of
the reason why you don't >> technically true. Anybody could
be
area where you as another adult.
>> You as another adult is a guardian of the state over
other people's children.
>> You don't actually think that. You know that's not true.
Obviously not true. But you're just saying it because it's something
that sounds bad. It's because you've used the term racist so
many times. You've said racist a thousand times. He never said
that. He never said
>> Just as much evidence.
>> Was he implying that Nick Sherman had some sort of bad
ulterior weird
>> up intentions? Was he implying that >> for these
daycarees having >> I don't know. I mean,
>> uh, he probably was implying it. >> He obviously
>> no children,
>> do not allow yourself to be gaslit by people that want
to lie. >> Presented for him. >> It's obvious what
you're doing with language being
>> over a Zack, right? >> It's so obvious.
>> I said that last chatter was wrong. Nick presented just
as much evidence for these years having no children as that chatter
presented for Nick being >> people that automatically already
agree with you. >> Why is it your comparison is going to
go over his head? No, I mean seriously, if you believe Nick Shirley,
>> did Asmold respond to the idea that they wouldn't let
him in because he was literally just asking to see kids and had
no identification and a bunch of like a whole entourage with
him? No, I don't know if as gold's really responded to that.
I think it's more like, well, wouldn't you be able to see kids
somewhere? Wouldn't there be some kids somewhere? It'll be a
lot of that kind of posting, right? >> Provided ample evidence,
which is just, you know, his own personal perspective that these
places are fraudulent.
Then anyone saying Nick Shirley is a profile is presenting the
same level of evidence. And not only that, but they're
not only that, but imagine if you went imagine if you went to
uh wherever Nick Shirley was uh living in like his home or the
place that he works at with a camera crew and consistently talking
about any sort of principle. They don't have any actual argument
at all. All they're trying to do is create weird insinuations
and other misrepresentations
in order to push an agenda that is supposedly trying to make
people not not think what's obviously in front of them.
>> This is a 23-year-old Mormon and you have a bunch of
weirdos like that on Twitter that are trying to paint him out
as a file. I mean really if you take a step back and you why
aren't they on a VC yet? Um because Asold doesn't see any reason
to get in a VC. I don't know. I think
when you when you get down to like propagandists like this, I
legitimately think without a moderator, there's no reason to
talk to them. You need a you need a third party there who's somehow
like not invested or who ideally hates both of you equally. That
would be the best case scenario. If you have a moderator who
hates both people equally,
that would be the best case scenario. So they have an equal like
reason to want to be like circumspect of both person's opinions.
But like without a moderator,
bro, I've like I've become like totally blackpilled on how this
looks. It just becomes who's better at making the other person
look bad when they aren't honest in the conversation. And that's
a totally different thing than figuring out what the honest like
fact of the matter is. one of the people is just going to be
better at pointing out how the other two are like sorry one of
the one of the two people participating is going to point out
how the other person um is disingenuous in a more effective way
and that person's going to be the winner of the debate. Yeah,
that's that's what's going to happen here which
but I I think a lot of people can debate I probably between these
two that might not be that big a deal. I totally understand why
Asold doesn't want to talk to Destiny, why Hassan doesn't want
to talk to Destiny. I fully get that.
Um, and I fully get why you just want to respond when they talk.
You just respond with your thing, right?
And again, that that that asynchronous thing is also fine. It's
totally fine. XQC offered to moderate a combo between Asmin and
Destiny. Yeah, I would not get Why would you get Destiny's best
friend to moderate? XQC literally XQC looks up to Destiny more
than food shops does. Why would you get him to moderate that
conversation? That's embarrassing. that the suggestion that XQC
could be impartial there when XQC's father is Destiny. Okay.
His internet father is Destiny is crazy. That's that's wild.
Best friend. I'm telling you his internet father is Destiny.
He has always looked up to Destiny and wanted to be Destiny.
It's why he does this exact kind of content, right? I know that
for a fact. We all know that. He wants to be a debater. He's
always wanted to debate. That's how it is, man.
XC has shifted manga, though. In what universe is XQC shifted
MAGA? What? Where is XQC speedrunning MAGA? Where is XQC being
MAGA? Where is Where is XQC attacking Destiny? Is that is that
like the tiny little edge case where he thinks he could attack
him but has 99% the same opinions? And by the way, there's nothing
wrong with that. I think Destiny's political opinions are fine.
I don't disagree with I don't disagree with a lot of Destiny's
political opinions. Purely sticking to politics only. I don't
disagree with a lot of that guy's opinions. I'm not trying to
say something bad. I'm just saying I would not want as gold to
have XUC who agrees 99% with Destiny being the person moderating
my debate with
That wouldn't that wouldn't work for me.
But I don't know. That's just me. If you guys disagree with that,
that's fine. Think about how deranged and weird that is. It's
insane. >> I'm not kidding when I say this. We have more
evidence to suggest that Nick is a file. XQC has shifted his
views to the right. Where where's the example of that? Where
have his views shifted to the right?
What what example do we have of XQC's views shifting to the right?
Can I get any example of this other than he showed up one time,
one single time when Aiden Ross had Trump over at his house or
some [__] XQC likes Asmin more than Destiny. That
is the biggest cope I've ever heard in my entire life. XQC likes
Asmin more than Get the out of here. Get the out of here. How
many times has XQC been on Asmin Gold's stream,
give or take?
Do you know when Do you know when XQC and Asold do get along?
Do you know the one time? It's the time they also happen to overlap
100% with Destiny. It's when it's on hour. Okay. It's when they
pull the odd rip cord. That's when they all agree on that. Yeah.
And nobody doubts that, but they're all on the same page. than
all of these daycarees having zero children in them because we
have evidence that Nick is trying to see children inside of daycare
facilities with a camera. Okay. Presenting that as a serious
thing in a serious tone is a little goofy. Okay. Okay. That's
He's trying to see children in a dude. At least do the voice.
Make it a joke. Okay. What the Okay. That is unironically
more evidence of Nick's
calling. Okay, so I know about in the one case I'm thinking of
here is I think when Destiny said blah blah blah, Destiny has
some take on this
voices. Don't let anyone tell you your voice don't matter. Okay,
what part of this do we disagree with? What part of this do you
disagree with? Hold on. Let's see what this is.
Musk wants to leave polit politics because he's afraid he's tired
of attacks from the left. And this is one of those Teslas getting
blown up. Which one of which what what do we disagree with here?
In what in what universe do you think this is a right-wing opinion?
Political violence is bad.
Wonder why XQC's community was saying this. # bring this back.
Um XQC has conservative people in his audience. He overlaps with
like Aiden and a bunch of other streamers.
He's always been resistant to his community. He always fights
with his community. XC's, you guys are crazy. Where where's the
alignment?
I'm telling you that XC will agree with Dest on everything up
until a point where it's like something like this where he'll
be like, "Oh, but also there's some stuff on the right that happens."
The right gets a rough deal sometimes, too. I can't do his voice
off the top of my head. I can, but I I need to do a whole thinking
about it thing. I need I need to work myself up to an XGC voice.
Okay. XC was Yeah, this is what I I'm talking about. It's like
vibes. There's there's like people have like vibes on this. I'm
telling you, XQC
and his community, I know I know two of his um
like two of his VIPs out of like 10 12 VIPs are literal DJers
that I know and have talked to multiple times. I know that he
likes Destiny's takes. I know that he likes Destiny's content.
And by the way, I'm not again not attacking him on that. I'm
just saying that that is who he gets like his base level of like
logic understanding. I'm not I'm not throwing the first stone
on that, okay? There's a long time that Destiny was a a content
creator who approached things well outside of his personal life
in a fairly okay way. Dude, I have a hard time evaluating old
Destiny content now, but I think acting like Tesla firebombing
is why Elon left politics is just dumb. Elon says, "Tired of
attacks." Hassan says, "Don't let anyone tell you your voices
don't matter." And FDC goes, "Well, there's a little bit more
than voices that might have pushed him out." I just don't think
there's anything categorically incorrect here. This is just categorically
correct. This is a correct take. You just don't like it because
it's defending Elon Musk and in that way every each and every
chatter defending is going like this is horrible to point this
out. You're just like Nicholas Dioro. You don't believe political
violence is good probably.
But you're like oh it's great when it's against Elon Musk. Elon
Musk fireball a Tesla.
How about you have some principles. Okay. Or eat a whole lot
of cake. One of the two.
Be as ugly outside as you are inside. Okay. Thank you. Okay.
I'm done with this one for a little bit. We're done talking about
FCC for a little bit moving forward. than any evidence that he
has presented
about these daycare facilities engaging in uh the the type of
fraud that Nick Shirley was trying to claim that they were engaging
in. >> There's like 50 houses of these people. Okay. The
only thing I don't want from Hassan here, I do not want Hassan
to go um the bar is if there's a single kid that proves there's
not fraud. That would be stupid. That would be really, really,
really, really stupid. Oh, there's one kid there. There's three
kids there. That proves there's no fraud. That would be really
dumb. I really hope he doesn't say that. Anything else from Assan
would almost be acceptable. But just the the bar being Well,
uh, there's like three kids there and now, uh, we've proven that
these aren't fraudulent.
Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness. That's not as bad. Okay, I'm
hitting play. I need to just do something real quick. I'll be
here.
and then you can't enroll any of them. You're going
in a lot of cases. The phone number goes to the government office.
Um let's see here. Oh, the amount of kids there is not even one
like fourth of what their occupancy is. And you add in all of
these things together.
Please, you don't have to die on this hill.
It's so obviously fraud. Any rational, reasonable person knows
that it's fraud.
is. I don't know what else to say. [clears throat] Give me one
second. I use that. Actually, >> you don't know what else
to say because you don't have an argument. >> Excuse me.
>> I'm saying you don't have any evidence for any of that.
I'm not against that being the case. never presented any
fraudulent uh these fraudulent communities like Asan and I have
a lot of common ground with things like uh public education
uh free health care all these other things like he and I agree
on all these things but you're constantly sing for these toxic
parasitic immigrant communities that are coming over here trying
to defraud us like you really I mean like >> somebody broke
>> yeah he's he's just full into the >> into the
building and they just happened to steal all of the documentation.
Like, I mean, how can you even for one second believe that that's
not an immediate scam? Like, >> see, this is what I mean.
He doesn't know. He doesn't know how this process >> Thinking
like that. >> He doesn't know how this process works. He
thinks that that documentation is the only way to conclusively
prove that there is like fraud happening. >> Wait, did
X cosign the video? What did X say about the video? Cuz from
what I Hold on, hold on. I could have sworn XQC literally said
the reporting in the Nick Shirley video was dog.
What do you mean he co-signed it? I'm I'm almost positive. Hold
on. This guy just said, "Oh, he co-signed the Nick Shirley video."
What?
I'm positive he said this video was dog. Wait, are you just lying?
Are you just openly lying right now? There's no way you're just
openly lying right now. >> You want me corporate filing
and and refiling and updates on on on paperwork?
How what the do I know about that?
Hey, did XQC did X cosign the Nick sir video? Kind of weird if
he so lived up to the point of mostly agreeing with you. I don't
know this [__] either. What
the last B? >> Wait, what did you what did you mean when
you said this? What did you mean when you said this? You said
did XQC were you asking legitimately if he co-signed the video?
You weren't saying he co-signed the video. You just went on a
whole thing where you were saying he definitely cosigned the
video. is some old guy show ME TWO PIECES OF PAPER which and
he's pointing at it like guys LOOK AT MY PHONE LOOK GUYS LOOK
WHAT TIME IT IS JESUS MAN CHAT LOOK AT THE time man yo DO YOU
GET THIS CHAT DO YOU GET THIS HOLY [__] like what
the I DON'T GET IT either >> had an $18 billion surplus
this bianium
>> uh no I see one it's definitely low IQ go watch Hold
on just because this chat message came through I have to Go watch
again. Donald Trump like kind of wondering whether he watched
the wrong press conference and he was actually dealing with like
a special needs kid. Hold on. Trump Nick Shirley. Let me go look
at this. Watch Nick Shirley try to just speak. >> My name's
uh Nick Shirley. I'm 23 years old. I'm 100% independent YouTube
journalist. And over the past year or so I've been able to go
to 15 countries. I've hung out >> I went to 15 countries
>> with people in the gangs of Brazil and the FLLAS in
the prisons of SOT. But yet the most dangerous places I have
been have been here in the United States unfortunately
and
>> uh the United States is more dangerous than Brazilian
fabellas and see
>> and I've had the opportunity to show people about the
protest Antifa here in the United States and there is nothing
organic about what they are doing here in the United States.
I've watched people be bust in from states. I've watched the
same lady at a protest in Atlanta
be busted to the protest in DC and then in New York City. Uh
there's nothing that is honest about what they are doing. And
they have signs. I've seen the same signs here in DC and in London
as well. It's a big organization and corporation that they're
they're running. And people may wonder >> big organization
and corporation that they're running
an NGO. What's a threat to us as Americans if we go? Well, you'll
be labeled as a fascist. You'll be labeled and they'll wish death
upon you cuz they wish death upon me. And just last week in Portland,
Oregon, I watched a lady get trapped in her car surrounded by
Antifa.
And her sister messaged me after seeing the video. She said,
"The only reason I think my sister was safe is because you were
there recording." I also um was chased out by a member of Antifa
who said he would smoke me. And next thing he knew, a DHS sniper
had lasers on his chest. If he was >> Thank God if that
ICE agent hadn't had a laser sight on his chest, that Antifa
guy was going to smoke. >> He's not there, who knows what
would have happened that day. Uh these people are very dangerous
and people wonder
how they're able to do it. It's the the reason is because these
these cities are not enforcing the law. And why should these
people be worried if the law is not being enforced?
And we are not far right, nor are we far wrong. We're just right.
And the We are not far right, nor are we far wrong. We're just
right.
This guy is like Down syndrome white Andrew Yang. Okay. Not left,
not right, but forward. We're not far right. We're not far wrong.
We're just right.
>> the truth about what's happening here in in America
with these groups. >> Just watch Trump's dude. Trump's
response. Oh, this guy also just like laugh openly being like,
"Dude, you're so [__] corny, dude. I There's a limit
to where the grifting goes, man. Holy [__] Nick.
What are you doing?" Watch Trump just be like, "You're a very
special boy, Nick. You're very special." I'm so glad you're here
with us. >> Is very dangerous. And I thank you, Mr. President,
and your administration as well for acknowledging that. >> Thank
you very much. It's too bad you have to go through it. >> I
know it's a little crazy, right, Mr. >> Well, you're going
to get to the bottom of it, so it's a very important thing you're
doing. Thank you very much.
>> You're going to get to the bottom of it, bro. Why is
that person just spamming, bro? All you have to do is sit here
and watch this for like 2 seconds. Just watch this. Hold on.
I'm going to not time that person out. I'm going to unban them
and give them a chance to just not spam. Just engage with the
chat. Follow along for 15 minutes and just see what you think.
Okay? Don't Don't just spam in the chat. Just follow along for
15 minutes while we talk through this and see what you think.
Okay? I am bad that
I am banned that guy. It's just a bot. If it's just a bot, then
it'll spam again and we can ban it that. Okay.
>> There or not, implying that that documentation was actually
stolen by the business owner himself.
>> Yeah. So, anyway, Nick Shirley completely brain damage.
Whoever asked, I forget who the chatter was that even asked,
but you're like, he's either a grifter or low IQ. No, low IQ
is the answer. Watch this guy speak in any non-scripted event.
That was scripted, by the way. That's the best you get from Nick
Shirley. That's that's him on a script. Watch him speak anywhere
where he's not scripted. It is tragic.
It's totally tragic to watch. Okay. He's a total [__]
goof. Once again,
once again,
the government has access to every single person and every single
child's information. That's not the only form of evidence that
the government has. >> That's what I thought. But unfortunately,
that's what I thought, Hassan. That's what I thought. And then
I found out that actually the attendance records are not wellkept
and they have a tendency to go missing. And without those attendance
records to check against months of stakeout footage. You cannot
prosecute beyond a reasonable doubt. The prosecutors won't even
pick it up. So you have to spend months staking these places
out watching every kid that goes in and out.
Right. And then you can check that against attendance records
and their their billing submissions. And then
only then can you actually charge these >> donated $3.
Nick is innocent. He's never been committed of any crime. >> That's
true. I've heard that. I' Somebody said that. Wait, why' you
Why did you say that? Why did I hear that exact comment earlier
today, dude? I People are crazy. That kind of comment comes out
all the time. >> The reality of the matter is if they wanted
to prosecute that. >> Oh, Nick said that. Right. He said
that himself. Thank you. Yes.
as I'm sure they will >> being obvious the >> I mean
what about the fact that they were investigated again your your
place gets broken into >> and then they happen to steal
all the
>> I'm sorry but if you think that's anything besides fraud
>> do you think that those records are the only way to
>> please stop
>> so again oh Hassan could get totally cooked here if
happened to read into this, which he definitely didn't. A song
could get totally cooked here because what's h what happens is
the record keeping is terrible. It's either illeible or the names
like it's either illeible, it gets missing, it's partially kept.
And then what you can do is if you only have the like poorly
kept attendance records, you can no longer prove that they're
lying about their their billing submissions, right? Cuz they'll
say, "Oh, I don't have all of them." And then what you can charge
them for is not fraud. It's for like you can basically find them
for having poorly kept records. I don't believe you could just
claw back all of the money you've given them. I don't believe
that's the case. And so, you can't even prosecute these people
and put them in jail.
And so, even if you could claw back even a substantial amount
of the money, there's not the actual punishment for the crime
that's going to come forward. And prosecutors won't even take
the case on if they don't think they can convict somebody. So,
you're just kind of like, >> I also want you healthare.
>> Do you realize how a degree of treatment programs work?
I also want to expand social systems, but we can't do that in
America if you keep in people that are negatives and scammers.
>> The case, >> you can't do it. >> You can
have mass migration of third worlders
or you can have robust social
>> Now, in my opinion, do you think that those records
are the only way to investigate this place? Do you realize how
any of these programs work? Once again, not saying this isn't
the case. You were simply speculating. >> If you don't
like that, too bad.
So anyway, listen, let me go back down and look at a few more
of these. Worked in 20 years in law enforcement. Never in my
years have I come across a case where they break in and just
steal documents. It's obvious.
It's obvious. Like [laughter] I I
running the grift off of this is a little bit funny, too. Okay.
Well, wait. Oh, he just saw it. You can see in his face. He just
saw the chat message. He literally just saw it. He just smiled
to himself. Look at those teeth. Look at that horse smile. Okay,
with those big buck teeth at the front. Who could hate this guy?
Also guys, I'm going to probably end on Twitch and head over
to kick for the rest of the stream. So,
Okay, kick.com/jok.
If you're watching on Twitch, head over to kick.com/jok.
The stream will continue there. Okay, good luck. I'll give you
like I don't know 30 seconds to move over. We'll see you guys
in just a little bit. Okay, bye bye.
Oh, by the way, I'll throw out a quick shill right now guys.
If you want to sub, donate. We got a decent amount of content
tonight, so you could sub, donate for more time. All right, $30
an hour right now. We are three subs away from another hour on
the stream. Thank you very much. Appreciate all the support.
You donate also through the TTS messages, all that stuff. And
then this is Patreon. patreon.com/jok. Okay, I'm not going to
do the whole shell. I just want to get a quick one out while
the Twitchers, we're moving over. Okay, we can go ahead and continue
on with content now. But there's no ev There's no evidence. Like,
do you think they're going to just come out and say I'm >> Update
for law enforcement.
>> Childcare centers at the center of Nick Shirley videos
were operating as expected when visited by investigators. The
Minnesota Department of Children, youth, and families said children
were present at all sites except for one. That site was not yet
open. I'm guessing that the number of children that were there
were significantly lower than their average billing day in in
most of the cases that people were uh featured or that there
would be gaps in the system. It seems like this is the kind of
thing going on. Again, can't say for sure and it will never really
be >> okay. At the center of Nick Shirley's video were
operating as expected when visited by the Minnesota Department
of Children, youth and family said children were present on all
sites except for >> Dude, the way this guy reads is so
funny. Update. Childcare centers at the center of Durley video
were operating as expected when visited by investigators. The
Minnesota Department of Children, Youth, and Family said children
were present all at all sites except for one. That site was not
yet open.
Yeah. So yeah, that's like he just he like speeds as fast as
he can through it and then
Yeah. Yeah. So yeah, so >> that site was not yet open.
The agency gathered evidence and initiated further review noting
the investigation into four senators were ongoing. Uh the report
by Minneapolis DC YF >> the song has been reduced to being
a >> Do you think the records are only way to investigate
the police or realize any of the program?
>> What speed are you watching at? This is 1x. We're watching
at 1x right now. It's not even 1.25. That's how fast he reads
>> Once again, I'm not saying this. You're just simply
speculating.
>> The government has access to the information of every
single parent. And not only every single parent, but also
>> government has access
to the info of all
>> Hassad, you're typing instead of listening. He's responding
to you. Hassad and their parents. Do you think
>> Had to guess between one and a
>> um this isn't a thing. Lj B A K S W R Y G R N S Z PN.
This isn't a thing. They don't charge you for having not enough
children, right? That's what a fraud investigation would be to
see because the issue is you're allowed 25 days per year to charge
for absence absentee students. So for kids who aren't there,
you're allowed to charge when they're not there 25 days of the
year. So just because investigator show up and you have three
of your normal 20 capacity, that does not mean that you are fraudulent.
That might be a red flag, although I don't know if that's ever
marked down as a red flag,
right? So you could have way lower capacity. And I believe that
in most of these cases, there's nothing even remotely. This is
one of the complaints in the report is they don't have the training
to discern when there might be fraud or what signs of fraud might
be.
So you could literally have like two kids there and say, "Oh
yeah, there's a flu going around in the community and they wouldn't
really question it." Now I don't know if that is the case and
I don't think they actually write down how many kids are there
in each report. They probably write it down in something they
keep internally but publicly they don't publish how many kids
are there. So >> have to say if you had >> Yeah,
they basically they basically can't track the kids. That's the
problem is for old the old system they can't track the kids.
By this year, they're going to have a an electronic system that's
going to mandatory like require them mandatorily to check in.
But that's just coming up this year, midway through >> What
did he ask? I didn't even hear it. What did he say? >> Government
access to all the infants and children and parents financial
status. Exactly. The government's in on it. That's why they should
be charged too as
>> just the worst response from Asen Gold. The the least
amount of engagement
>> Yeah. Uh the government's in on it. That's why they
should be charged too. Tim, fire Tim Walls. >> What's the
percentage? >> Wait, if he actually believes that, then
Wait, what do you mean? What's the >> Sorry. Sorry. I read
something. >> These places
>> What's the percentage?
>> What's the percentage? >> Income qualifications.
They can't,
>> bro. Their daycarees, their own house,
>> I know. Without the government looking at the parents
background,
this would
what is this Hassan percentage of speculation? What is the what
is the question that he asked me? These place have income qualifications.
They can't get subsidies without the government looking at the
parents background. >> We'll give it a little bit longer.
>> What was the question he asked? >> We'll give
it a little bit longer.
>> But no, I think he I think he does bring up a good point.
The government does have access to this. That's why there has
to be a federal investigation. I think that what your uh your
rebuttal is actually proof of my point. Your rebuttal is proof
of my point, Hassad. I think the government's in on it. I not
only do I allege a conspiracy, I allege an even bigger conspiracy
than it surely >> Yeah. What about that, Hassan? Put that
in your pipe and smoke it. >> What's happening is that
they're directing the federal government to not go after these
people because they want to secure
this community. I think that's what's happening. >> Why
don't we talk then? >> Let's check with the chat first.
I feel like it's such a simple question
of being a fan. >> Why don't we Why don't we talk then?
No, I'm not. We're not going to Oh my god.
bro, you're in the chat. Can you stop? >> Are [laughter]
you worried? >> Oh my god.
>> We agree. No, >> he he literally is Boomer in
that he has to say the things he's writing. Well, he doesn't
have to actually. He's probably just doing that for stream, but
he's like saying the things he's writing. I can't type fast enough.
>> It's a simple percentage. >> Stop begging. >> Jesus.
I'm not going to debate. I'm not going to go and argue with you
about this or whatever because again, if you look at all the
evidence presented and you don't come to the conclusion that
there is like a 99% chance that this is a scam, you're lying.
You're lying. You're obviously lying. It's so clear. I just think
the best source for this is that 2019 report. And the way the
primary investigator, the person who was managing the investigators,
described it was, I would say, 50% fraud. If by fraud you mean
it's like a couple moms who get together and they start this
business and they collect a whole bunch of money from the government
by taking their kids there, not really supervising them, not
really teach them, not really do anything with them. They just
kind of let their kids sit there, right? They don't even really
watch them that well. They sit on their phones. say it's not
even close, right? That that report is the best evidence because
that's describing what the problem is. Like, hey, it's it's not
that they're fraudulent, that there's no kids there. It's that
they're ext they're reporting additional kids. And it seems like
this community has come together to say 50% of they're saying
50% of the I guess people that they look at are fraudulent. Like
50% of the people applying and and running businesses through
the grant are operating in some fraudulent fashion and that the
kids are not being taken care of correctly. that a lot of these
places are for like pre kindergarten training, pre pre kindergarten
teaching, and the kids don't get taught anything. There's no
ABCs. There's no learning. There's no ABCs or numbers. It's just
they just sit there, right? But that was what the investigator
said. Now, here's the
That wouldn't be
Wait, I'm saying 50% fraud. Wait, what are you What are you confused
about, Elder Baby use? I'm literally I'm literally explaining
to you I'm qualifying how you should look at this that there
is fraud. I'm agreeing with Asmin Gold that there is fraud, but
he's he's saying there's a 99% chance there's fraud. I mean,
there's a 100% chance there's fraud, but it's it's what how pervasive
is it. And what what does the fraud look like? The fraud doesn't
look like these are totally ghost businesses. And it's kind of
presented that way that they're just totally ghost businesses
that don't exist. One second. I'll be right back. Give me two
seconds. I ordered food and I just wasn't sure if it my light
was on. I'm good. So, it's not that these are totally ghost businesses.
These businesses all exist, right? I just got here. Is Hassan
saying there's no fraud? Uh Hassan is saying that you can't show
like basically there were kids there and the allegation is there
were no kids, therefore no fraud. And it's like no, the allegation
is that there are kids there, but it is still fraudulent. That
is that is the measured
factual allegation,
right? What did you order? A burrito. >> Uh-oh. They're
all saying he's a now >> Yeah, it's not a debate. That's
why I asked about the percentage. >> What is the question
that he asked me about the percentage? I didn't hear it. What
was the question? >> Give me space to go. No, it's okay.
It's He's a communist, right? Everybody gets their own space.
>> Doesn't he concede earlier that there's fraud? Feel
like he doesn't know enough about it to even have a consistent
position. I think he said there might be fraud, but trying to
paint it as like that whole community doing fraud or whatever
is disingenuous and it's race baiting to get people off of the
real issue, which is persistent fraud at the highest levels of
income in the American government and amongst American wealthy
the American wealthy class. Right? That would probably be his
fully fleshed out opinion that it doesn't matter in the grand
scheme, which I don't think is true. I would say there's something
less dehumanizing, although it is bad, of like doing tax evasion
in a way where you're not like defrauding specific people. I
would say this is a certain kind of fraud within the child care
system where you're using money earmarked for kids to get kids
taken care of and you're doing fraud on that money. That's like
a a specific like localized kind of fraud that is far more offensive
to most people. You got to grapple with that as well. >> What
was the question out of the
>> He can't against his beliefs. answer speculate on the
probability of fraud. Let me see if it did.
>> Kind of feels like you don't want to dunk on me easy
style. No, I just don't like debating. I don't debate about video
games.
>> And again, you're going to try and do the strategy.
Listen, Hassan,
you are the Jake Paul of debates.
You have no problem gassing yourself up talking about how much
you want to debate me or debate some other, as you like to call
them, slop tubers. Watch. Whenever it comes time to debate Ben
Shapiro on capitalism or debate destiny, for some reason you
want to have that same attitude.
>> Wait,
knowing what your criticisms are doesn't necessarily make them
not true. Just cuz you know what the criticism is, right? Doesn't
make it not true. Although I do like Asmin Gold doing a little
judo there. He knows. He's like, "People are calling me a [__]
for not debating Destiny, but you're also a [__]
for not debating Destiny. So, can we have a truce amongst >> I
don't really want to hear about, oh, yeah, I want to debate you.
You're going to come in and be the big guy and everything like
that. >> I did want to debate Ben Shapiro. Barry Weiss
pulled it very publicly. I don't know why. I don't know why you're
saying
>> I did want to debate Ben Shapiro. Barry Weiss pulled
it
>> because Yes, because they wanted to debate on something
else.
Barry is
deplatform.
Assan, did you see what I said about that?
>> I need to be deplatformed.
>> I did cover it. I talked about it.
>> Did you see it? >> Is Asmin Gold just wrong on
the facts here? Damn.
>> Barry Weiss publicly said I needed to be
>> Yeah, but did you did you see what I >> No, I
didn't see what he said. Again, he's only he's only able to talk
because he can at least control the narrative a little bit in
this circumstance, but he can't control it if we're having a
back and forth conversation. Even a couple even a couple statements
immediately cause him to back away from his initial claims, right?
>> And this is the reason why he wants to control the narrative.
He wants to make sure that like at most he will respond to me
chatting in his chat. >> That this
is probably so much worse than >> It's both things. [clears throat]
It's just both things, right? Like, it's obviously both things.
No, no, no, no. I do think there's something to be said for I
don't think these people will engage in good faith. You would
need a moderator to like go and and actually um like try to make
a make it so that they're committed to being intellectually honest.
I don't think that would go well for Asminold either, but I do
I do think there's something to be said for like a lot of one-on-one
conversation. People are just totally disingenuous when they
do it.
like they're just they're the goal isn't to have like greater
understanding. I do think as I think both of these people would
change their opinions if the goal is greater understanding,
right? You just need moderators. You need somebody who's willing
to like try to moderate it and
the moderator needs to not be influenced by the people.
That's pretty difficult. Maybe that's why that's where Barry
Weiss steps in, but that never happens. No, it doesn't. So, I
don't mind them saying they want to do it, you know, in a in
a d what do you call it? like a an asynchronous way. I don't
mind that. It does suck when two people are streaming and there's
like a show that has to go on and then one of them's chatting
and the other one's talking. The clips is kind of good. I think
um writing like Reddit posts would be good as well. Like Twitter,
doing Twitter back and forth is pretty good. I said Reddit post,
but Twitter back and forth would be fine, right? You can even
this fraud is insanely
bad. And I don't think that it's just with these dayc carees.
I think it is with the entire
government. Destiny would be the perfect moderator. I don't like
saying that, but I feel like you would. I don't think Destiny
would be the perfect moderator because I think Destiny is a totally
like amoral loser who shouldn't have a platform. So, I kind of
totally reject that. But other than that, yeah, cool. healthare.
Uh, it's with healthare, it's with health and human services,
it's with food stamps, it's with welfare, it's with tax write
offs, it is [__] everything. And if we had the, in
my opinion, I think that we are spending close to if not over
a >> Oh, I agree with Hassan on this one. >> Public
private partnership is garbage.
It really doesn't work in a lot of cases. The the only reason
this exists is because this totally thing where people are like,
"Oh yeah, a private company here that would be way better." >> Trillion
dollar
fraud every single year. >> And if you don't believe
>> timed out, >> you're out by the bot.
>> I think Minnesota fraud is abysmal. A byproduct of private
partnerships to be combative. Okay, good. Then that's fine. Great.
Then we're on the same side. >> Hyperfocusing. Stop trying
to make this an argument about some >> No. Claiming that
>> Okay, great. Good. We're on the same side. That's amazing.
I'm happy.
>> Are the claiming that third world
Here we go. >> Yes. And I I might we'll get this in a minute.
But >> claiming that third world parasites are coming to
fraud be investigated. >> The issue. All I'm saying is
I think that it is so much worse >> than uh than what people
realize. >> Like I grew up, you know, I I don't know
for a while. Uh I'm claiming that third world parasites are coming
to do fraud is the issue I have with your claim. >> The
overwhelming
>> of migrants.
>> Hassan, we just agree totally on the public private
partnership. And Hassan's like, "No, you're scapegoing immigrants."
And his like and as like yeah well immigrants should stop doing
fraud. Immigrants should stop being leeches. It's like well that's
the argument there. That that is the >> Claiming third
world parasites are coming in to do fraudist and work
everyone else. There will always >> when these people and
they advocate for racial racial ethnic voting.
>> They stay inside of their own community. They don't
assimilate into America. >> They send money back home.
funds terrorism. This is all just made >> Then on top of
that, there'll always be fraudsters. They should be jail. Of
>> the only majority of migrants just want to exist and
work alongside everyone
>> Okay, great. Well, if you think that, then why are you
trying to lump in and then take the Oh, jeez. I'm debating with
his son now. I just realized
>> you've got you got me. You actually got me fraud. >> Okay.
I I can't I said I was like two messages. I've actually Jesus
[__] Christ. migrants coming to do >> one more
and then I'm going to move on. >> Somebody could engineer
this to be like way better. By the way, somebody could engineer
this audio to be like both of their primary audios, not one of
them talking over the other like on their stream. That would
be like way way way better. But unfortunately, it's just them
yapping over each other. >> Okay, you got baited. No, I've
been baited. You You did get me. So, okay. All the migrants want
to work alongside everybody else. That's great. That's lovely.
That's amazing. That's really nice. So, don't launder the good
reputation of all those migrants that want to look good and work
with everybody else and have no problems. Don't launder their
reputation through these Somalian scammers. Don't do it. Because
I agree with you. You know, I'm not anti >> I technically
he's doing the opposite. He's taking the hardworking immigrants
who come to America and laundering the Somali's reputation with
their their work, right? That's the opposite.
I think
>> she talk complains and doesn't give an example. Episode
45. Wait, what did I complain about between them complained about
it but didn't give an example of them talking over each other
or you bring up something from way before
>> should be able to come over here for sure, but it needs
to be in the best interest of American citizens and right now
it's not. When you have these people coming and they're scamming
the system, they're getting these massive amounts. the audio
I this is the example of Hassan going I am typing out a message
now and as a gold is literally going and I can't hear both of
them at the same time it's difficult that's what I'm talking
about the example is what I'm
>> when you have these people coming and they're scamming
the system they're getting these massive amounts of welfare it's
going to a private daycare in their own house they
by the way he is just like working his way up to just describing
how racism works how many people we could help that are Americans
if we were able to take that money and give it to them. And I'm
not saying I hate Somalians. I don't hate any of that. You're
saying thorough parasites coming to do fraud? Yeah, exactly.
Because they are. What else do you call it?
89% are on welfare.
What the is that? Why are we bring Why are we bringing people
in just so we can give them welfare? We have people here that
are on welfare.
Oh, we should probably try to figure out where that think tank's
like numbers came from. That would be good. Just in terms of
working against sort of the racist propaganda, we should figure
out where that think tank's numbers come from. Is that true?
89%. That's from a think tank. I can't remember what it was called.
Hold on. What the [__] was it called? Um, history.
Let me see here.
Nope. Assistance. No.
It was like a think tank and I Oh, cis.org. Oh, I found it. I
found it. I found it. I found it. CIS.org.
So, this site published this thing right here. Welfare use rates
in Minnesota by household. Any welfare cash, food stamps, Medicaid.
So, Somali households very high on the government teat. Okay.
Taking a lot of money from the government. And then I think it's
like welfare use rates in Minnesota by households with children.
So, then there's this one. basically any welfare. It's 89% of
wealth of Somali households with children. And I think there's
another group here. Yeah. So the gray is basically there's this
and then Somali immigrant households with children greater than
10 years in US that you've been here for 10 years. If this were
true, this would be cataclysmic. This would be like, oh, this
is absolutely dog for this group of like there's something wrong
with this group of
So, well, immigrants aren't a problem. Immigrants aren't broadly
on government programs more than anybody else. If this were true,
but I don't know. It just says the 2014 to 2023 censuses, basically
the American Community Survey. And I I don't know how we would
determine this. I'd have to go try to find these numbers myself.
But I would say if these numbers were true, which I I don't this
this specific cis.org, this is like a think tank with a total
bend on what they're trying to put out for information. So they
have every reason I have every reason to suspect they've like
kind of massaged these numbers to get them to look this way.
If this were just the case, we could say this in a vacuum. Somali
people in America after 10 years, they're still on government
assistance significantly. They're still taking like a ton of
it. I'd say that's probably a problem. That's probably like a
problem that's really disproportionate for any any other immigrant
community. You have to figure out what's going on there to help
solve it. There's something massive going on that's wrong there.
Okay. I believe I put two links at the numbers and the other
thing the there's no Somalian breakdown though. Yeah, but we
don't know what. So they say it's from this, but I don't know
if you got like I'd have to look for somewhere with cross tabs
or if you can get like raw data. Maybe there's they're like building
this from raw data or something. I don't know. Yeah, I don't
know. No, it's not Tim Mo's buying votes. The buying votes thing
is totally because the Somali population is not that big in
Minnesota. The the population is not big enough that you would
do this to swing votes in that tiny block.
They're big enough maybe in Minneapolis that that paying them
off in Minneapolis alone could be beneficial.
They're not big enough in the state to be worth state politics
going, "Oh, it's really important we get this one block." That's
That's not true. Oh, you're mocking eyes gold. Okay, fine. Okay,
>> I drove by back I was I was like on the highway. I'm
driving by on the highway. I see a homeless veteran on the highway.
He's got a sign painted the American flag. I've got to see this
guy live on the street. >> You could just say it's households
and not immigrants. You could just say it's households, but I
don't know if that really changes anything tangibly.
Like, do you have a do you have a hypothetical where the like
the number of households that are on welfare and and the numbers
being like that disproportionate? Do you have any hypothetical
where that makes like more sense? Where that makes like, oh,
this this all is fine? I actually don't know how that would be
the case. need like 10 Somali living in a household. Maybe like
five five times as many Somali living in a household as native
born maybe and then maybe you get there possibly but you don't
really know.
Anyway, sorry we we continue on with this video. >> Great.
Well, they're living in a man. >> By the way, I should
say as much as I'm commenting on this, I have extreme
I'm looking at this with extreme prejudice. I do not have a reason
to believe these. I do not count them as real until I can validate
them myself. this this site the cis.org. I trust them as much
as I trust the the KO Institute. Okay. [__] these
totally like these totally motivated think tanks that just they're
trying to put out propaganda and vaguely like couch it in science.
Anything like this KO Institute these okay
they are fake [__] almost always. Okay. I don't I
don't trust them. I'd have to validate the numbers myself.
though. I just want to drive that home one last time on both
sides of this because
I just want to make it clear that as much as I'm saying hypothetically
if this were true, this would be a big problem. I don't have
any reason to believe it's true until I can get more information.
Okay, that's sufficiently couched.
>> This is
pro-immigrant. They say anti-immigration, pro-immigrant or Yeah,
I think they they say they're anti-immigration, proimr, right?
That's the tagline.
Low immigration,
Yeah. Okay. Okay, bro. Okay, bro. Low immigration, pro immigrant.
Okay, dude. >> Is that fair? And now I'm debating
>> They're American citizens. Number one, I don't even
know if the 89 claim is correct or not. For the >> Stop
defending the indefensible.
>> What you guys are doing right now is the same as you
were criticizing MAG people for doing foring
my argument. >> Not everything has two sides. >> I'm
not. You're shamanning my argument. >> In the same way
that I supported and I agreed with you with what you were saying
with Epste. I'm I'm not. You're straw maning my argument. Well,
you're mad at the way that I'm saying it. >> I don't I
don't think it really matters personally. You want to say it
matters. I I don't really give a [__] >> You
can see me. >> The point is I'm not even going to say >> Han
doesn't have any emotions right now. He is focused way too much
on trying to up his WPM. Okay. I'm not really mad. You can see
me typing >> that. I'm just going to say
>> they're not healing anything you say. And [laughter]
uh you can't type and listen at the same time.
And um anyway, just stop debating. That's what he does. Just
stop talking to him. >> He's all audience like stop debating
him. Stop debating him. I wonder why. I wonder why they're >> You
go and you see any of this stuff, you go around in Austin or
anything else, it is really really bad. And I think that the
you're right that the Somali thing is not that big. It is the
tip of the iceberg.
>> IT IS NOT EVEN THE tip of the iceberg. It is the This
is the one gorillion. Okay, this is the one gorillion tweet.
Let me go find this one. Cuz the
Anyone who's been around illegal and low-income immigrants before
knows the Minnesota daycare scams are just the tip of the iceberg.
This is happening all over the country and at a trillion dollar
scale. Voters enable it because of white guilt. Politicians because
of the votes. What's the entire US discretionary budget, by the
way? Hold on. US discretionary
What is the discretionary spending
um 1.7 trillion is discretionary. So they're like almost the
entire discretionary budget is purely being wasted by immigrants
is this comment. Okay, the entirety of the discretionary budget
is being sucked up by immigrants and wasted. Like it's a totally
insane comment. It's an obviously insane comment. Okay, now he's
being hyperbolic, but it's like it's just totally insane. It's
mathematically impossible. Okay.
Yeah. By the way, I believe in that discretionary budget is the
entire military budget, too. So, like it's the the entire military
budget is in the discretionary budget. Somehow, you're getting
a trillion dollars spent a year on immigrants sucking up all
the lifeblood of the country. Okay.
How how if Aspen Gold ever complains about the military-industrial
complex taking too much money and then also says it's a trillion
dollar scale for immigrant crime, immigrant fraud in America?
Come on, man. Come on, man.
Maybe he's saying over decades or something. I don't know. I'm
trying to think of like how this would make sense. It's just
like it's a level of alarmism that is totally fake. Like obviously
fake.
So kind of goofy. Assan is bad.
>> He's seagull on the tip of the iceberg. >> Oh,
interesting. You've spent 76 hours just talking about third world
terrorist. RS
you spend >> I will say there's you can't say don't ever
focus on this cuz it's not the most important thing. That's a
disingenuous argument. It's disingenuous when he does it with
um it's disingenuous when he does it with Palestine. It's disingenuous
when he does it here. But you could say like bro don't you think
there there is a point where it becomes true. Okay. Where you
do spend like every single day just constantly railing on the
parasitic immigrants that are draining the lifeblood of your
country. And it's like that is sort of the the entire the total
content or the the character of your content right. You're not
really complaining about all fraud. You're sort of zoning in
on these people now. Yumo for the whole year. Is that really
the case? I man I think Asminold is getting dangerously close.
Okay. You watch a couple Fentes clips and he's really funny and
then suddenly you're just like they're stealing trillions of
dollars from us.
Immigrants are stealing trillions of dollars from us. Right.
It happens gradually. I don't I don't blame Asthma Gold for not
catching it. Happens right overnight. Okay, you just watched
like two Nick Fentes Instagram reels and you've been totally
scioped into believing these immigrants have destroyed America.
Okay,
>> it shouldn't be defended just because it's a bunch of
migrants or immigrants from any other community >> to do
fraud. But to say that there is not a problem in a bunch of people
that are 89
of fraud
>> done by Somali
in min and let's say >> you don't see oh yes somebody broke
into the building >> is a stole all the doctors >> you're
doing Elon's
propaganda
>> for him >> anyway so yes
>> you spelled propaganda propaganda Anda
Propaganda. Wait, that it's definitely with an A, right? I I
think in my head I'm like, you definitely spelled that with an
A, right? Yeah. Okay. Oh, thank God. Thank god. I just started
making fun of this guy and then I'm like, wait, I'm correct,
right?
Oh, thank God. I for I I thought it was one of those moments
there. Sometimes I get a little hottie about stuff. I'm like,
I think I'm right and then I'm wrong. Nothing more embarrassing
than those moments. Okay.
Very scary. Very scary there for a
>> Every moment that you spend implying that immigrants
are coming from my point of view
is a moment you're doing Elon
Musk
doing Elon Musk. >> I think that really if there were people
>> Yeah, they are both doing the same thing. They're both
basically ignoring each other.
You know, people like like Americans doing this or like some
random Mormon community doing this. I think that everybody would
be, you know, together agreeing that it's very bad. But because
it's a minority community that is an immigrant community, there
are people that are just um categorically defending them for
that reason
>> that's true. That is true. There are people who are
categorically defending this on the virtue of it's really up
to say bad things about an immigrant community. That is happening
100%. >> 89% is false. probing Trump's verbal attack on
Somali.
84% of individuals report in Minnesota. Not just Somali
showed us provided to us shows
reporting
that
I don't think that I really have the alignment there. I think
there's a big problem. >> Mute him when you talk, please.
Wait, he's reading it. I think he's reading what I said. >> A
fraud like them. >> Uh yeah, I think there's a degree of
>> Have you ever seen an episode of Law and Order? Criminals
often try to obscure
It's important to be able to find the fraud, but to put the blame
on the people that are being defrauded, I think is basically
victim blaming. And that's the reason why you go to a CVS and
everything's locked up. >> That's the entire reason why
I'll always focus on immigrants. Sometimes it's homegrown blacks
that steal everything and ruin everything for everybody, you
know, guys. You know, sometimes it's just the homegrown blacks
that do it. It's not always the immigrant blacks. Sometimes it's
the homeown CVS.
It's because all of these people like, "Oh, yeah. Well, you know,
you shouldn't have done that." Absolutely not. That should
>> That was rude to do to Asmin Gold. That's probably not
what he means, but that's what I heard. Okay. That's what my
lib brain told me. That's how my lib brain challenged or translated
it for me. Okay. >> Do you think Somali's commitment to
the United States? Probably I would say
less than 1 to 2%. Maybe actually maybe a little bit higher than
that. >> Not even. That's crazy. I think if they were defrauding
if if Somali were defrauding the government program in any in
Minnesota entirely, I still don't think they'd get up to that
level of fraud. Maybe they get up towards that level of government
fraud. Maybe, but I don't think so. I don't think so. I think
it's got to be like.1%
like 2%, right? You just think of how much of the federal budget
goes to Minnesota or any state that there's any significant Somali
enclave in. What is there? There's Minnesota and Ohio. Is there
even another one? Hold on. Let me see. Uh, perplexity.
What states have largest Somali
Let's see here. Let's see what it is. Yeah, it's it's basically
Minnesota and Ohio.
Technically, Washington's got a little bit after you get through
Washington with which has 15,000. Ohio's got 20 to 25,000. Minnesota
63 to 64,000. Okay. But once you get past Washington, there is
no significant enclave. If you took the entire federal budget
allocated to Minnesota, Ohio, and Washington, you could maybe
if if they stole all of it, maybe you could get up to like that
percentage of the fraud, right?
I think
I think >> very very like if if you're asking like if it's
a percentage, a very very low percent. I think that they are
committing a very low percent. Now, person loss to a Jewish comedian
is Charlie Kirk or Ben would annihilate him. Well, can't do the
Kirk anymore, but definitely do. You guys can keep fantasizing
about it though. >> But this is the reason why I supported
Doge. Like I feel like government wasting money. >> Watch
here. But I do think that it's unfair that he can talk and you
have to type. Even if I disagree with you, he should talk to
you. There we go. Elon Musk cuz you save free speech and investigated
fraud with Doge. Well, they didn't even do enough of that. Yeah.
Come on, man. These people are not
AI literally just gave up. AI didn't even attempt it for me.
Okay. AI was like literally couldn't possibly be
literally couldn't possibly be that. But Minnesota, it's 1% of
the population. Ohio, it's 2% of the population. Everywhere else
is lower than 2%. Okay. Like they're just not capable of stealing
that much money.
>> Far enough to pull this off alone. >> Was that
Ohio stat? Was it here? I was reading my own [__]
I'll roll back 30 seconds. Lost to Jewish comedians. Charlie
Kirk or Ben would annihilate him. Well, can't do the Charlie
Kirk one anymore, but definitely not.
>> That's particularly goofy cuz he was set to debate Charlie
Kirk, right? Like,
yeah, one Charlie Kirk, he gone. Okay, RIP, Charlie. But he is
also set to debate the guy. So, it's weird to point out that
he wouldn't debate Charlie Kirk. He was supposed to debate Charlie
Kirk. Are you saying Hassan's responsible? Hassan realized he
up. He couldn't possibly debate Charlie Kirk, so he sent one
of his goons to Utah. I don't think that's possible. You guys
can keep fantasizing about it though. >> But this is the
reason why I supported Doge. Like I feel like government wasting
money here. But I do think that it's unfair that he can talk
and you have to type. Even if I disagree with you, he should
talk to you. There we go. >> They're pissed off at Elon
Musk because you save free speech and investigated fraud with
Doge. Well, they didn't even do enough of that. >> Yeah.
Come on, man. These people are not smart enough to pull this
off alone. The government are the ones enabling the >> He's
actively trying to actively trying to move away from reading
my comments. part of the this is part of the reward structure
is that the government you trying to get a dialogue going as
shown to his audience he's a coward. I think that there are definitely
a lot of people in his audience that will look at this and think
Asmin Gold is being a little cowardly. Is Kai still alive bro?
Show us the shot collar bro. She's dead.
>> And I think there will be some people there will be
some people in there that'll just like engage in self soothing
behavior.
engage in self soothing behavior. Especially because like the
moment that we start talking, if you noticed, he said he agreed
with me quite a bit. >> And that's precisely the problem
here. He doesn't want to have a conversation where he will for
he will be forced to concede on a lot of the things because a
lot of the things that he said about what my positions are uh
are are are wrong.
So, if his audience saw what my actual position was here and
then actually he had to sit there and defend what he's saying
in front of someone who is who is a little bit more knowledgeable
about what's going on in in uh Minnesota, he would have to fold
because immediately he would be like, "Well, yeah, we agree."
As he did, right? You're getting really good at debating. I wonder
how the Clippers are going to spin him ducking you. They'll say
Asmin Gold destroyed Hassan or something like that. I watch you
both for different reasons. What needs to happen is you listen
to what he's saying now and actually respond later cuz he's assuming
you're listening even though you're engaging in your chat. Honest
opinion. Why won't he just talk to me directly then? This is
what doesn't make any sense.
>> Hold on. He understands that it is the exact same reason
he gives for not wanting to engage with Destiny, right? Like
it is precisely the same thing. I don't know why any of these
guys
basically anytime there are lots of people who don't want to
debate like other people, right, who don't want to talk to them.
There's like a million different reasons you could not want to
debate somebody. But with Hassan and Asold, they both have the
same reason for not wanting to debate Destiny. Asold
passes that reason over to Hassan.
He claims it's the Twitch ban though. It's not. It's not the
Twitch ban. It's not even that he would lose, although he might.
Like Destiny, by the way, also I don't think Destiny I do think
Destiny's bad faith when he meets his like match. When he's when
Destiny is debating somebody who's like his equal in a debate,
he is bad faith. We watch him do it with Pisco. It was embarrassing
to watch. Okay. And Pisco wasn't good enough at calling it out
and let it happen. And there was just not really much you could
do. You need a moderator there to like pause him and make him
go back and answer things. But Destiny most of the time is good
at analyzing information, is good at making arguments, is very
capable of just beating people in debates straight up. Right?
He's like Lance Armstrong or something. All right? Like he is
good at debating. It's not like he's a bad cyclist. He's just
on steroids. Like when he needs to, he'll he'll take the steroids
and he'll win the race. Right? So I do think there's like reason
to avoid him if you're a serious political actor. If you just
want a conversation, I in my experience, Destiny can be good
faith most of the time. If I was having a non-confrontational
conversation with Destiny, I was fine being good faith with him.
But I then when I'd have a confrontational conversation, probably
the one around um forethought comes to mind, although I don't
have I have very different thoughts on that whole situation when
that played out. The one where Dan tried to get Forethought fired.
He was so bad faith in that conversation. I was just correct
in that conversation. He was insanely bad faith in that conversation.
It was wild.
Um
yeah, I think when he's like in the wrong, he will be he'll start
to do crazy. He starts to do the the hyperbole finding thing
where like he So, if you remember back to the Pisco debate where
Pisco says something that's like a little out of bounds AND DESTINY
GOES, "OH [screaming] MY GOD, I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU WOULD SAY THIS.
ARE YOU REALLY SAYING?" AND THEN WHEN Pisco be like, "Hey, you
kind of mischaracterized me here. Can we go back and talk about
it?" And Destiny would just keep talking and move on. It's like
Desi's hyperbolic about him, hyperbolic about the evidence he
has that Denims was uh like responsible for the CPS call. And
those hype that that hyperbole doesn't ever get called out in
the same way. But Destiny will constantly farm that in a conversation
he's not got good footing in. Right. And that's as as that becomes
more prevalent becomes more obvious, but it's really difficult
for his cult to pick it out. Like they don't pick it out at all.
Um
trying to think Apple River sabbing was a huge tell. I mean he
was totally wrong on that as well. He just Yeah, he was totally
like lying and disingenuous on that as well. At least that one
I understand why I understand why he lied cuz he didn't want
to pay me the money. But yeah, that was that was particularly
bad, too. True.
Um,
hyperbolic about everyone giving Cyber hugs and kisses. Yeah,
true.
Anyway, so that's that's how he will be in a debate. Just most
of the time he doesn't have to do that. Most of the time he can
be correct in the facts. Like he's debating some random right-winger
conspiracy theorist. He doesn't have to go and and do any of
those things, right? And he can be correct and then people like
how he beats up on those people. So they'll follow him and and
kind of explain away the other stuff. It's not hard to understand
why he's popular.
Think Mel Mestny wouldn't spazz out and call for the head of
Hassan on a stick mid debate. No, I don't think so. I think he'd
try to stay calm in a conversation with Assan. He's also like
totally spiraling in manic. So I don't know. Maybe might not
apply. If he's in control, he's fine. If he's like totally spiraling
in manic still, I'm not totally sure how he how he docked. Very
hard to call >> have this conversation. He's the only one
who doesn't want to have this
I think that for Somalians like yeah they are voting as a block
but
this would happen
unspoken rule kind of that keep the gravy going and we're going
to keep voting for you and it's ironically another version of
Republicans cutting taxes for rich people and then rich people
continuing to fund Republicans. So the problem really >> the
thing is like one of my worst qualities as far as like debating
or whatever one of my worst qualities is unironically that I'm
very
you know I'm very consiliatory in my tone whenever I have this
kind of conversation with people even if I completely oppose
their world view.
>> one of my biggest problems is that I'm too nice and
too charitable and too >> The irony is I wouldn't be looking
for easy dunks or anything like that. I just wanna
I just want to actively have
>> Genuinely [__] by people yell at me all
the time in my own community. If you're in here for the first
time ever, you'll know this helps them around the >> People
actually come to my community and yell at me all the time because
I always try to engage in good faith when I have these sorts
of conversations.
>> And I think that like clip farming as a >> actually
destroys any kind of good faith that could potentially happen.
>> It makes it much easier. it makes it much easier to
frame your opposition's argument as something that it actually
isn't, right? >> And and that's what it is. Like that's
what he would rather continue to do. >> And the more I
write in his chat and the more that his uh his community sees
that,
um some will say it's good that you're actually not talking to
him, King. Uh we don't want you to feel uh >> I do think
in a lot of ways. Were you a DGG head in those days when he and
Destiny tag team got wrecked by Nick?
No, I didn't watch any of it back then, Koser. I was I was around
in DGG when Destiny debated Nick on Israel on Fresh and Fit and
I told everybody he got in that conversation,
dude. Oh, the best was when Destiny was trying to ask like Nick
was talking about some guy and [clears throat]
I think Destiny was trying to argue that this guy supported Israel
and the guy died in like 1935 or something and Destiny was like
trying to argue it. It was like he had done no he didn't know
anything about Israel. It was like so embarrassing to watch.
It was so
so sad to watch. Anyway,
let's see here. He prepped for a Holocaust debate. I remember
that. Um,
yeah, I thought it went pretty badly for Destiny. I He said he
prepped for Holocaust debate. He didn't prep at all. In fact,
he had a star over the night before and was like doing totally
like unrelated drama content like on his stream the whole previous
day. He didn't go and study for that debate at all. He showed
up totally unprepared and got his wrecked unfortunately. Yep.
Yep. Anyway, >> insecure about your worldview. We don't
want to We don't want to feel insecure about our worldview, but
there will be plenty of people. No, I believe that one was Anya
Dayar. That was the Ana Dayar thing when DG went and looked up
all of her past on Reddit and called her a liar and made her
cry and then Destiny freaked out and was like, "You guys are
crazy. WHY'D YOU GUYS LOOK UP ALL OF HER PAST ON REDDIT?"
YEAH.
Kind of crazy that DG does stuff like that, right? All the time.
And there's like a huge backlog of all of those instances happening
that everyone's aware of. >> People who go, I think there
should be open dialogue between the two >> just in case.
Just in case Destiny was thinking he's going to paint my community
as one that does that. Just remember I was in DGG. I know all
of the instances of doing them doing that like dozens of times
over the past 5 years.
>> Right. He talks about me every day. It's still human
trafficking and kidnapping. Yeah, I think so, too. And and and
I I I think that they >> uh that one wasn't doxing. That
one was um just looking up her Reddit, which to be fair was weird.
>> This is this is an issue. Maybe Hassan will agree with
this. I think that they need to take the people that are employing
these illegal aliens. They need to do a discovery process on
their personal and work computers and correspondents surrounding
work. And if any of them acknowledge or express a reality or
a knowledge information that they are knowing that they are knowingly
employing these illegal aliens, I would like to see them charged
with human trafficking. I would because that's effectively what
they're doing. And until we have these business and and I I'm
very frustrated about this, you want me to be honest that ICE
is not doing that. Uh, I think I should >> Are you Are
you telling me food shops won? That would be very funny.
>> Is that what you're telling me? You telling me that
Food Chops was DGR of the year? That would be very funny to me
>> doing that because I I don't really And this is another
thing. I don't have any
I don't have any genuine animosity for Mexicans or any other
people from South America or the Congo or any of these people
that are coming over here. I actually don't. I know a lot of
other people do. you know this viewoint that I have but my view
with it is actually very simple >> I don't actually
>> bro when do they debate holy they don't they don't debate
they as not going to debate anybody it's just this back and forth
we're analyzing this back and forth to see who's being good faith
turns out neither of them is being good faith neither of them
is engaging they just continue to say their own propaganda over
and over again >> hate these people I don't disown
I just understand that they're coming here and by doing so they're
causing us problems but I don't view them as inherently bad or
evil people. I don't disagree, but the solution is documenting
people and then punishing business owners, but shifting the blame
to migrant workers helps the owners get away with the two-tier
labor system that depresses
Well, I I I think that really it's so so this is Hassan said
that um I I agree with you actually. I do uh I don't agree because
the migrant workers are definitely to blame to an extent. Like
you're talking about workers. We're not talking about Somalians
at this point, right? It's the workers.
I I agree. I said this is the problem with clip watching because
this is my actual >> Basically like think about it like
this, right? It's a carrot on a stick.
>> They are the ones putting the carrot out there. They're
the ones that are creating the incentive for all of these people
to come and overrun America and depress down all their wages.
And then here's the other big problem is that these people,
>> it's really simple to understand and nobody will admit
this. Nobody wants to admit it for some reason, but as AI gets
better, as automation gets better, as software fills in gaps
in just general white collar work, those jobs start to disappear.
Those jobs start to become more efficient. And it's not really
in a way that you need to fill that gap with like additional
workers. You don't need additional workers cuz it's like busy
work that once it's done, it's just done. It's just like automated.
You don't need to do it anymore, right? And we're starting to
get rid of jobs that way. Then for a lot of jobs that we did
need a worker for for those white collar jobs, it's cheaper to
just send it to India. Trust me, you get four Indians together,
which is what or sorry, you get four people from a third world
country together who you can pay like a quarter of the money,
right? They will do more than one random white person in America.
That's just true again. All right, so that's also getting rid
of some jobs. And then you have a ton of people coming in like
just immigration wise and they're also lowering the value of
your labor. If cons if there was consistent economic growth that
was driving jobs, that would be good. That would be okay. It
would all take care of itself, right? But we're getting to the
point where the number of people you have is no longer linearly
or even really effectively at all scaling the
right? The the GDP growth that's happening is all from AI data
centers getting built. You're not seeing actual like production
of American workers driving that GDP growth. That's not what's
driving it. Like the company sorry the country is significantly
stagnated
and human capital is not driving productivity in the same way
it always has and every single model is set up believing that
that base assumption that human pro human capital and increased
human capital drives productivity. That base assumption is the
assumption under which all modern economics lies like it it all
is built on that pedestal.
Once that's no longer true basically a ton of economic theory
doesn't work anymore. And people are trying to tell you, "No,
no, no. More people's always better. More people, economies of
scale." That has always been true throughout history everywhere.
I do believe in the American economy right now. That is becoming
less and less the case every single second of every single day.
That is the problem. That is the the core issue that basically
faces all Western countries right now. One or here's the core
issue. It's it's that whole thing, but you have to offset that
with the idea that your workforce, every workforce in the western
world is aging, is reaching retirement. They all have retirement
savings. They have retirement plans through the government, right?
Some kind of pyramid scheme where basically the next generation
pays for the the previous generation or sorry, the Yeah, the
next generation pays for the previous generation's retirement
or two generations past, right? Okay. So, you have that problem.
So you need taxes to pay for these people to retire because you're
not going to have as many workers and people aren't having as
many kids. So you need someone to come in and work, but you're
basically human capital is being devalued. So you're bringing
in this devalued commodity, further depressing it, further depressing
the value of it, right?
And all in an effort to try to get your taxes back up and it's
just not making Yeah.
Yeah. It's it's the humans need not apply problem. It's the Yes.
Basically as you increase the number of horses in any area you
you created more work product you created more ability to be
productive. So horses were a great indicator of economic growth
and economic activity right but then suddenly in America the
highest economic activity place on earth the population of horses
plummets. Does that mean the economic productivity of that area
plummeted? No. It just meant that horses weren't being used in
the same way they were before. Humans are experiencing that same
issue, that same cliff right now. And it's going to keep getting
worse. Right now, by the way, it's still amazing. Just you should
really be relishing right now. It might seem like it's the end
of the world. We haven't even really started down that path yet.
Okay, that's You should be relishing right now. How did they
start using horses?
I don't know.
What do you mean? I don't know. Horses were around, dog. I don't
know how they started using horses. I don't even know what that
question means. There might be a thing there, but just ask it
in a general sense because I don't know what you're trying to
ask.
This is generally what I think about it.
Yeah. Let's see here. When will that path start happening so
I can withdraw my money from the market? I mean, it's happening
now. No, you shouldn't withdraw your money from the market. The
market's the best place your money can be. The market's still
going to keep going up. The market's still going to be stable.
The economy is going to keep
It's just that human capital is going to be less and less effective
in the economy. It's going to be less and less productive in
the economy.
um or what you'll see is more of a K-shaped thing where the broad
majority of human capital will lose value, but there will be
a small amount at least intellectual capital. Listen, in terms
of blue collar jobs, it might be that the robot the robotic revolution
never comes. We never have like robotic workers ever that are
able to like be complex enough we just won't have the materials.
It's possible that blue collar work spikes really bigly bigly.
I just said bigly because complex one said
a lot that like blue collar work just generally like being like
a maid being whatever that might spike. It's possible. But if
you keep bringing in immigrants who don't have training, who
can't work in any white collar job, then they're going to do
those jobs for nothing, right? >> People come here, they
have a bunch of kids, they also bring sometimes their relatives.
They're living off of the
especially through things >> just like >> I don't
get what we're talking about anymore. We're talking about why
immigration is not a core good. Like high immigration equals
GDP growth equals growth in general. It's because the value of
human capital is being is being like cratered
and bringing in more people is not is not creating economies
of scale in the way it used to. Used to create economies of scale.
You might you used to be able to basically build stuff fast enough
that you could you know you could sell it. You could build more
factories. You could scale up your economy. You could build like
a whole infrastructure around some industry. And that is not
happening in the same way because the people benefiting the workers
in the AI industry are not humans. They're chips. Is this confusing?
How is this confusing to people? This is like really obvious
to me. Some people aren't getting it. We're talking We're talking
about basically unfettered immigration that the illegal immigration
in the United States was a huge advantage for a long time. It
was an underclass of workers who would do the the dirtiest hardest
jobs and you basically had so much so many work opportunities
in the United States. Your your labor was valued so highly that
it didn't even matter.
Right? That's that's it. So, it used to always be good. I think
at this point the the illegal immigration, the mass illegal immigration,
this is an obvious
I think it's a pretty clear obvious bad even economically. Um
at least for the average person, GDP still go up, but I do not
think it's good for the average person. The average person with
the average education, the average IQ, I think it's bad for that
person.
>> That's my opinion. your
>> especially things there like um
>> did when they >> we need to incentivize more Americans
to be farmers and laborers.
>> Yeah, but that's just costs, right? That's just more
costs. They're not going to go be farmers and laborers for below
minimum wage, which is what those jobs pay now. How you going
to get them? How are you going to incentivize that? You to just
subsidize that industry so whites want to go work in that industry.
That totally distracted me. like food stamps for example or education
system. they do cost the taxpayer a lot of money uh you know
these illegal aliens
>> and they don't do it directly but they do it also through
things like um >> uh like identity which is extremely common
like it was a very like I even knew people that knew people I'm
not going to get into specifics here who
>> you're never ever going to pay somebody
more than the possible economic output that they generate right
you're never going to pay them more even even when you heavily
subsidize an industry you're basically never doing that Okay.
So, if your if your solution to the problem with the economy
is Americans do the lowest paying immigrantonly jobs, you are
that also doesn't work. This is why it's like an unsolvable This
is like it's why it's a really problem, right? You're not going
to Nobody's going to pay $100 for strawberries. That industry
stops existing overnight. You can't pay them enough to make up
for the jobs that aren't going to exist anymore.
And then it's just going to be like only the very smartest people
will have like very highpaying jobs and the economy will continue
to like um disconnect like there will continue to be this higher
class this upper class lower class disconnect. It's solvable.
Allow immigration.
Um sure. Uh hold on. What is this name? Are they not even Oh,
they're not even in the They're literally banned from the overlay.
Why am I looking at Kickhat? Never mind.
Yeah, this person's dumb.
regularly go down to uh Hassan's been >> it's not it's
not capitalism it's not capitalism it's like this level of technological
advancement if it's not being done under if it's being done in
the way it's being done now you're just going to reach okay maybe
it's capitalism a little bit you're just going to get surfom
that's what you're going to get you do need unfortunately I do
think probably ultimately it's worth having the conversation
about socialism communism because if you if you basically break
through to the singularity right Now, with it all being in the
hands of private owners or the Saudi princes or the Chinese fascist
government, right, pretty much all roads lead to the average
American or average Canadian is in every one of those scenarios.
It's not that I'm anti- capitalism. Capitalism has been the best
vehicle we have for everything. It has been probably we might
have to figure something out else out at this point. I I just
don't know what the answer is. It's rough.
I truly believe that up until this point in time, capitalism
has been the thing that makes America great, makes the western
world great. It has been the best system under which things can
operate. But we're reaching uh sort of like some place where
we're at diminishing returns.
And I don't know what the solution is. I have to think about
it. Think about it a little bit more. Seems very concerning >> Austin,
it's like >> And by the way, you'll never you can't prove
this. So if anybody goes, "Well, don't you know communism's been
responsible for?" Yeah, I know that. I know that. I'm unfortunately
just capable of looking at the current situation and going, "Oh,
that seems
I don't think it's latestage capitalism. I don't think it's what
Markx described. I don't think that's it." I think it's like
a technological singularity we're reaching. That is a totally
different thing that wasn't predicted cuz it's not going to be
just like it's not going to be broadly like capital owners and
everybody uses their machines to make products that they sell
and they they get all the benefits of the labor. No, the labor
is going to not be valuable. The labor will eventually reach
a place where it's not valuable. Anyway, Riverside, it's like
the other side of I35, right? It's like on the other side of
like downtown. >> Why is this go to response, I agree,
but not actually agreeing? I don't know. >> There's not
as many now anymore. >> I said I think blaming people for
wanting a better life just like a great grandparents did when
they came here is wrong and helps the billionaires keep this
current broke. >> Uh AI hella stupid though. Okay, if AI
hella stupid and AI can't be fixed with the current technology
that's being invested in, then you then America is building its
ghost city all across the country right now. And America is going
to be right. America is investing all of its capital, all of
its capital investature, all of its capital investments entirely
are going into something that if it's not effective, that's probably
worse. That's probably like America has wasted an entire generation
of investment of capital investment in nothing.
That might be the only thing that is worse is if this isn't the
case. I'm presenting you like the best case scenario. Okay? It
might actually be worse.
systems and their social security numbers and because gay rword
they would take care of >> it wouldn't even be close to
actually being worse. Okay. Not worse than AI surfom. Sure. But
I'm saying it's like probably you're looking at
I I don't think so. I think America's structural advantages probably
make it always the global hedgeimon. But it it's bad. It's real
bad. Okay. It's real real real real real real real bad. These
kids are starting to take care of >> That's why America
just needs to start building military equipment, okay?
Subs, aircraft carriers, jets, just start building. Start spamming
military, okay? Until we figure out what the [__]
is going to happen. Just spam military until we can figure out
what's what the hell is going on, okay? >> Shame these
kids to get extra tax refunds and then split the refund money
with the parents. And and this is the kind of stuff that unless
you've seen this stuff happen, you don't even realize that it's
happening.
That's it. East first to 15th Street.
>> Watch this. Zing
with realize they have more common ground than he realized. >> Business
owners are the >> No, Hassan. They can get my country.
Go back to the migration. If it wasn't for the business owners
paying these people under the table, they wouldn't be here. That's
the facts. >> No, the American empire will collapse. It's
too extended and too in debt.
Okay.
Who is it in debt to? And how is it in debt?
Quick pop quiz. Who is it in debt to and how is it in debt?
It's in debt in American dollars that it prints.
Guess what? I could be a trillion dollars in debt to you and
Jade in Monopoly money. Okay.
Does that mean anything to you? You owe me a million dollars
in Monopoly money. Okay. You get to decide how much Monopoly
money there is. The whole supply of Monopoly money. Well, they're
they are inflating the debt away right now. And that was what
they're risking doing. Um, over time, America will win that situation.
America will win that situation. Um, oh, the Federal Reser I've
heard of this. The Federal Reserve, eh, how does that work? Surely
that's not some kind of like private entity that people collect
dividends out of. No, that couldn't be possible. It's a part
of the government. We should just hit play. This is how people
get shot. That's probably what Charlie Kirk was asking right
before it happened. Okay. He probably sent a text the night before.
I think we should audit the Federal Reserve.
He gone. He gone. That's 100% true. It happened to me.
100% on that point as well. A lot of families still do this.
Of course they would.
>> Why would they not do this? And this is the problem
that I have is that I think that there are a lot of shared values
and like common goals that even Hassan and I have. >> This
is how this is how also this is how Asold presents himself as
like a reasonable centrist for the record. I
he's living
scams and this is >> very different attitude overall than
what he was saying
migrants and all this. >> So yeah, I'd want us I hopefully
hopefully there can be an alignment watching a free guy in the
chat making sure that we have actual Americans, real Americans
that are getting this money
>> when Tokover, are you a millionaire or a billionaire?
You're a millionaire. Give 50 subs right now. Prove it. Prove
it. Prove it. And don't say some gay like, "Well, I'm a millionaire
because I don't give my subs to streamers." Don't say that. You're
gay if you say that. Real Americans. Imagine that.
>> We don't need Americans. Our economy is not expanding
faster than our current
Oh my god. Billions of dollars. You really think it's it's the
worst place is Minnesota? Give me break.
>> We can also see what happens. You flood the market with
new workers looking at the effect on women beginning to work.
Uh yeah. I mean, I don't know all the details about that, but
I could see that being the case. Sure. That's why I want you
emotions.
And the thing is that >> if you want to deal with the problem,
you have to women joining the workforce was actually an example
how of how like the exact same effect that immigration has where
like even if those people aren't as effective, if they're only
worth like like I'm saying this as if I were trying to convince
a misogynist, right? If you thought women were like half the
worker a man is, right?
That's still going to increase the output of your economy really
significantly in the 60s7s 80s, right? It massively output it
massively increases the output of your economy. It does. It's
just it's basically all human capital increas like translates
into an increase in
productivity in in like actual output from these companies.
Yep. You have to approach it from like 10 different ways. You
don't just approach it from one way. You have to over $1 billion.
Those committing fraud in Minnesota will be caught and prosecuted
to the fullest extent of >> there are no real Americans
which I meant. He meant the Europeans. Yeah. I just don't understand
like if you are
you wouldn't be hyperfocusing on the [__] the Republicans.
entire Somali community that you are suspecting of doing fraud,
implying that every single Somali person that's come here is
actually a third worldist like a third world parasite simply
here to steal funds. Okay,
that's it. The reality of the matter is even in terms of like
keep pressing him especially on the women going into the workforce,
it destroys in his Chaz Chaz Tradife stance. I don't even know
what he's talking about there. Hassanabi, you worked your entire
life on your fake image just to destroy it all by shocking your
dog. You rword. Baha.
Yeah. No, everyone everyone hates me now. The thing about Hassanabi
is that he's really like and then but also those but then again.
Yeah. Anyway, so that's kind of it. Nice.
Wow. Owned. He said women starting the working flood the market
like immigrants. Wait, what? Let's see what else he's talking
about. >> Watch it and then I got distracted. Where the
did it go? There was a video about this and I don't know where
the hell it is.
>> He banned me before I could answer his questions. Things
are going in the chat. Look at what I was trying to get.
anyway, all right. Well, he's off the he's off talking about
a chatter implied if it Adolf slob played dumb to appease. Wait,
what? Yeah. The point is the point is it's not 89% on welfare.
It's only 8%. Scroll down and see the Somali on welfare. No,
they're saying that benefited from the specific public assistance
program, mostly Medicaid. So, it's not even like uh welfare in
the sense that they think it is. It's just Medicaid, right? Um
but worth noting, Bowser said 95% of Somali in Minnesota are
citizens of the United States and 58% of them were born in the
US. Okay. >> Is he reading this as Bowser? >> It's
that they think it is. It's just Medicaid, right? Um but worth
noting Bowser said 95% of Somali in Minnesota. >> He is
saying that as Bowser >> citizens of the United States
and 58% of them were born in the US. Okay. February report from
the Libertarian Ko Institute using a different methodology found
that immigrants consume 21% less wealth.
This is so stupid. I hold on this is this is the dumbest thing.
They're like, "Oh, CIS said these things about Somali immigrants
in Minnesota." And it's like, but the KO Institute said immigrants
are good overall. Like, oh, okay.
Are you What? Why do you pretend that this is a rebuttal to what
is said above? It's literally not a rebuttal at all. It's an
evasion. Again, this is the CIS study. >> Entitlement benefits
in native born Americans on a per capita basis in 2022. That
report looked at the percentage of total dollar amount of spending
on
uh for immigrants and US-born residents and accounted fewer means
tested programs as uh welfare and also included social security
and Medicare which are considered entitlement programs. The CIS
said that in 2022 54% of households headed by immigrants including
naturalized citizens legal permanent residents and people without
legal status use one or more major welfare program. The problem
with this report is do you believe that people who are naturalized
citizens are American citizens? Do you believe that people who
are born okay do you do you believe that people who are born
with Somali ancestry but are born on US soil are American citizens
or not? Now, the reality of the matter is for programs like the
uh the CIS, they try to claim that American citizens born natural-born
US citizens are actually not real US citizens because they were
born to one or two families uh or one or two parents that are
uh either undocumented or, you know, not an American citizen
at all. Okay,
that's the issue. That's the problem. just like literally anything
he could do to not grapple with the facts.
Right. And again, I'd be fine with him saying, "I don't trust
this place at all." But he's going like, "This place is racist."
That that speaks to motivation. You can speak to the motivation.
But if I I feel like it's disingenuous to look at that and not
go, "Well, if that's true, if that if it were if we were to figure
that out, that would be a real problem." I the refuse to do that
just baffles me sometimes. Well, it only baffles me in that like
I think it's dishonest, but I I guess it doesn't baffle me in
that I know that Hassan is dishonest. Those people are American
citizens and the entitlement programs are claiming that this
is just welfare is also silly because it's like Medicaid, Medicare,
Social Security, things like that. And the idea is like what
what are we supposed to do if someone is of Somali descent, even
if they are uh an American citizen that they shouldn't have access
to Medicare or Medicaid or Social
>> It's ridiculous. We're getting to the end of this. I
don't really care about this anymore. What else is there? There's
Nick Wick Lee at the uh he ran his event today. He's running
his apprentice type event. I don't know how that's going to go.
I don't even know actually how to start covering it. I think
I had somebody was sending me like clips and stuff. Maybe take
a look here. Give me a second. There's like a nickel thread for
for this nickly CX
Um got a couple different things. For some reason, I got linked
this as another as gold. Search reveals users are searching for.
Wow, I just typed it in. It actually shows the recommendations.
I can't believe it's real. Disgusting. Now type in horse. >> Horse
and lady. Horse and lady, please. Horse and lady, dude. >> Okay.
[laughter]
>> Wait,
this video is funny.
Dog dog attacks. Dog licking peanut butter off. Dog walking.
Dog licking licking peanut butter off. But I think that's like
is there's a story about that. That's a copy past about that,
right?
>> Do women date men in their 60s? Do women fantasize about
men? Do women think about you? Do women ever miss their guy after
rejecting them romantically?
that's rough, dude. There's no way he just reacted like that
for
I'm sorry. That is just funny in a vacuum. No way.
NO.
NO WAY. WHAT the is this? Are you kidding me,
bro? I have been wondering. So, I might have to like find that
and green screen green screen it. Okay, dude. Dude, there's no
way. No way. NO WAY. WHAT the [__] is this? Are you
dude? I feel [clears throat] like that's the first time I've
ever seen him laugh. Like, for real. Like, he's actually just
so he finds it so funny. Kidding me,
bro. I have been wondering. So, so true, brother. So true. Do
women think about you? Bro, this is the most pathetic.
Are you kidding me? These pathetic fat
60 years old. Try girls. Do girls do girls like acne? Listen,
this is one I can't complain about. Guys,
there's some 14, 15 year old guys that are on Reddit looking
this stuff up, right? I get it. [laughter]
Hold on. Do Wait, wait. Do girls Do girls have Adam's apple?
Do girls Wait, guys. Do girls have Adam's apple? Girl, Do girls
have Adam's apples? >> I was there, too. Let me answer
the question for you. No, they don't. >> Then whenever
my acne went away, they still don't. Do guys How about guys?
Do guys like tall girls? Do guys care about hyperpigmentations?
Do guys like it when their girlfriend is all over them? Do guys
like when girls make noise? No, they don't.
Uh, no. Uh, that's actually a really simple answer. Uh, no they
don't. They don't. That's Thank you. Absolutely not.
Okay. Do men How about men is really bizarre as a bizarre I'm
not even going to spend a lot of time litigating that. That's
like really bizarre to me.
Do men care about? I told you it's just a bunch of fat women
on this website. I said for a fact. I said it's a bunch of fat
hoes sitting around talking mad on Reddit. I said, "Yep, there
it is.
they're all fat. They're all He's a He's a pick a group to be
mad at about this search history, right? It's old boomers, it's
little kids, and now it's fat women." Oh, and uh like simp like
pathetic simps. Actually, it's a bunch of fat women and incelss
on Reddit
that want to that want to see a dog >> eat peanut butter
off a dude's dick due pregnant. Oh, he thought that meant dick.
He thought that P was for